der Ukraine Konflikt wird hier gleich
die Abgeordneten beschäftigen ich kann
ihnen nicht ganz genau sagen zur Sekunde
meine Damen und Herren ob die
ursprüngliche geplant das Programm da
drin um halblos geht ich nehme mal an
dass die Umbaumaßnahmen etwas länger
dauern und es bis viertel vorgeht und
deswegen werden wir noch Zeit haben für
ein Interview zu diesem Thema Ukraine
der Kanzler aus Hamburg hat einmal
gesagt lieber 100 Stunden umsonst
verhandeln als eine Minute schießen das
war natürlich Helmut Schmidt und der hat
gleichzeitig den NATO-Doppelbeschluss
durchgesetzt auch gegen seine Partei
weil er auf Augenhöhe auf Stärke
verhandeln wollte dieses probiert im
Moment auch die westliche
Staatengemeinschaft unter Führung der
Amerikaner die Nato und gestern war ein
entscheidender Tag da haben nämlich die
Amerikaner und da hat die NATO das
Antwortschreiben über sendet an Vladimir
Putin der ja Forderungen gestellt hatte
in Richtung westlicher Gemeinschaft zum
Beispiel dass die Ukraine nicht in die
NATO eintreten darf weitere Staaten dort
die Osterweiterung dort nicht
stattfinden darf und das Waffen
zurückgezogen werden sollen die Antwort
der Amerikaner war die meisten
Bedingungen können wir so nicht
akzeptieren über Abrüstung können wir
jederzeit gerne verhandeln was heißt das
jetzt das will ich fragen meine beiden
heutigen Gäste Nils Schmidt der
außenpolitische Sprecher der
SPD-Fraktion und Jürgen hart in der
gleichen Funktion für die cdu/csu Herr
Schmied was heißt denn das nun was die
Amerikaner und die NATO da haben Putin
geantwortet haben sind wir einem Krieg
in der Ukraine jetzt näher oder hat die
Diplomatie da noch mal die Oberhand
gewonnen also mein Eindruck ist dass in
den letzten zehn Tagen die Diplomatie
deutlich die Oberhand gewonnen hat es
gab verschiedene gesprächsformate
angefangen von bilateralen Treffen der
Amerikaner und der Russen über den NATO
Russland trat OSZE treffen bis hin zu
Formaten wo Europäer und
Ukrainer und Russen direkt im Gespräch
waren zuletzt das von gestern im
normandie-format Frankreich Russland
Ukraine und Deutschland auf Ebene der
Regierungsberater das zeigt an die
Diplomatie gewinnt an Stärke und wichtig
für uns ist dass in dem Antwortschreiben
jetzt an Putin wir in der Sache klar
sind aber Dialogbereitschaft gezeigt
haben in der Sache klar heißt es kann
keine Einflusssphären geben innerhalb
Europas es gibt keine abgestufte
Souveränität europäischer Staaten
Russland muss akzeptieren dass die
Ukraine aber auch die osteuropäischen
Mitgliedstaaten der EU und der NATO
volle Souveränität haben und Russland
kann deshalb nicht drauf setzen dass wir
die Ordnung von 1990 mit der Karte von
Paris einfach über Bord werfen sondern
wenn dann gibt es Gespräche über
Abrüstung und Rüstungskontrolle und das
ist für die europäische Sicherheit auch
unbedingt erforderlich
ja Herr hat die Russen haben
mittlerweile so bricht Beobachter
120.000 Truppen zusammengezogen an der
ukrainischen Grenze Herr Putin hat jetzt
die Antwort auf seine
sicherheitsförderungen die er gestellt
hat vielleicht im Wissen dass die
Antwort so lauten könnte wo stehen wir
jetzt in diesem Konflikt hat Herr Putin
jetzt schon was erreicht weil die
Amerikaner die NATO sagt lass uns reden
über Abrüstung was er immer gut ist oder
ist er enttäuscht dass eben die NATO
sich weiter nach Osten ausdehnen kann
wenn das die Staaten dort wollen weil
die NATO dahinter steht
zunächst einmal möchte ich feststellen
dass der Druck den Putin mit seinen
Streitkräften an der ukrainischen Grenze
ausübt ja eher den Wunsch der Menschen
in der Ukraine zum Westen und zur NATO
zu gehören verstärkt also wir werden ja
gar nicht in dieser Situation Russland
wäre gar nicht in dieser Situation das
gilt im übrigen auch für Georgien und
andere ehemalige sowitrepubliken wenn
Russland sich wesentlich freundlicher
mit diesen Staaten auseinandersetzen
würde insofern provoziert putinen im
Grunde das was er verhindern will durch
sein Verhalten und das ist etwas was wir
deutlich machen müssen und was auch er
und sein Umfeld begreifen muss dass er
letztlich Russland entfernt von der
übrigen Welt ein Stück weit auch
isoliert ich glaube in den letzten
Wochen ist auch deutlich geworden dass
dieser Militär Aufmarsch keine
Unterstützung in der Welt findet auch
kein Verständnis für die russische
Position und umgekehrt dass er damit
letztlich alle im arkönig macht die
ansonsten ja vielleicht eine Rolle
zwischen Russland und der europäischen
Millionen und der besten einnehmen
könnten also insofern glaube ich da
stimme ich nicht mit voll und ganz zu
die letzten Tage haben schon das
diplomatische Gewicht eher auf die Seite
der Ukraine und des Westens verlegt eben
aus diesen Gründen er hat keine
Unterstützung in der Welt für seine
Position allerdings hat er einen
Truppenaufmarsch an der Grenze
organisiert der mittlerweile ein
Großteil der gesamten russischen
Streitkräfte umfasst
wer möge dabei nicht akwürdig seinen
Blick auf das was geschickt so kann man
das natürlich sehen Herr Schmid auf der
anderen Seite es ist ja so dass
tatsächlich Schweden und Finnland
überlegen ob sie NATO-Mitglieder lieber
werden dass ich ihnen alles zu
unheimlich was Putin da macht damit
würde Putin ja das Gegenteil von dem
erreichen was er will aber putin ist ja
nicht dumm kann es sein dass der
russische Präsident dieses ganze
veranstaltet hat und jetzt die an
Antwortbrief der NATO und der Amerikaner
nutzt um zu sagen jetzt marschieren wir
da ein in den Donbass weil die anderen
wollen es ja nicht anders
also ich sehe jetzt nicht ein
unmittelbaren Einmarsch bevorstehen aber
die bedrohungstage bleibt ernst so wie
Kollege hart es festgestellt hat die
russischen Gruppen sind immer noch da
sind hoch mobilisiert und damit ist zwar
die Diplomatie jetzt wieder in der
Vorhand aber leider haben die Russen
noch keinen Schritt zur Entspannung
beigetragen und das wäre jetzt sehr
wichtig dass Russland diesen hohen
truppenaufzug zurücknimmt und dass wir
im Donbass selber in der Ostukraine ein
verlässlichen Waffenstillstand bekommen
und das müssen jetzt auch die nächsten
Schritte sein dass wir im
normandie-format so ganz praktische
deeskalationsschritte vornehmen
Waffenstillstand in Flechtung von
Truppen entlang der kontaktlinie in der
Ostukraine und vor allem dieser
russische Truppenabzug die Motivation
von Putin aus meiner Sicht ist klar er
versucht den Westen zu testen die
Geschlossenheit des Westens zu testen
und er braucht
außenpolitische stärkedemonstrationen
nach innen die Reihen zu schließen
schließlich ist Russland im Inneren
alles andere als besonders innovativ und
wirtschaftsstark seit 20 Jahren sehen
wir so was wie stabile Stagnation die
Abhängigkeit von Öl und Gas ist
unverändert hoch die Innovationskraft
der russischen Wirtschaft ist niedrig
die meinungsfil hat falsch die
Zivilgesellschaft wird unterdrückt was
für Putin zählt ist die Erhaltung der
Macht und das wieder mit
außenpolitischer Stärke erreichen das
normandiefern Format das ist ja insofern
positiv als das gestern wieder an
Verhandlungstisch verhandelt wurde wenn
auch nur auf kleinerer Ebene mit
außenpolitischen Beratern das war ja
auch schon mal anders dort sitzt nämlich
die Russen gemeinsam mit den Ukrainern
und an einem Tisch und die Franzosen und
die deutschen moderieren das ganze man
hat sich jetzt gestern in Paris darauf
verständigt das waren wohl sehr
schwierige Gespräche war zu hören man
hat sich verständigt man will sich in 14
Tagen in Berlin wieder treffen aber die
Russen haben auch klar gemacht es muss
Bewegung dahin die Ukraine müssen
das eine oder andere Forderung die sie
gegenüber den Separatisten haben
verändern es geht da zum Beispiel um die
Wahlen die müssen erst stattfinden bevor
die Ukraine wieder dieses Gebiet
zurückbekommen und an den Grenzen
Kontrollen ausüben können dass es
zumindest die Forderung der Russen und
interessant ist Herr hart dass die
Russen sich dort gar nicht als Aggressor
sehen sondern als Vermittler für die
Separatisten sie tun so als wenn sie gar
nicht Partei wären hat denn dieses
Format überhaupt die Möglichkeit mit
winzigen Schritten den Frieden zu retten
also ich finde auch an dem gestrigen
Ergebnis gut dass man gesagt hat Minz 2
also das was bereits vereinbart worden
ist und was ja auch hier in Berlin vor
einigen Jahren in einem Gipfel noch mal
bekräftigt worden ist dass das weiter
die Grundlage ist und ich sehe auch
keine Alternative zu dieser
Vorgehensweise allein diese
schutzmachtrolle die Putin sich anmaß
gegenüber Menschen in einem Gebiet in
einem anderen Land das erinnert mich
halt fatal an das 20 Jahrhundert wo das
ja ganz oft als Argument für
kriegerisches einmarschieren verwendet
wurden nicht zuletzt hat Hitler seine
Angriffskriege auch begründet mit diesem
angeblichen Schutzbedürfnis von
Deutschen in anderen Ländern das klingt
total schrill in meinen Ohren und ich
finde wir sollten als Deutschland einen
starken Beitrag dazu leisten dass Putin
Kleist der Westen ist geschlossen in
dieser Frage und wenn ich eine kleine
Kritik anmerken darf an der schwierigen
Situation in der die Bundesregierung ist
ich hätte mehr gewünscht dass der
deutsche Bundeskanzler in den letzten
Tagen unsere Partner in Osteuropa zum
Beispiel nato-parte aber auch EU-Staaten
Finnland Schweden die sich bedroht
fühlen Baltikum dass er sie besucht dass
er mit den Regierungschef dort spricht
dass er den Menschen das Gefühl gibt ihr
könnt euch auf Deutschland verlassen
denn das ist so man kann sich auf
Deutschland verlassen aber in der Art
und Weise wie die Bundesregierung das im
Augenblick nach außen trägt sehe ich
ganz klar Verbesserungsbedarf ich würde
da auch gerne unterstützen das ist ein
ein gut gemeinter Ratschlag und wenn Sie
so wollen jetzt keine parteipolitische
Kritik ich aber es wird mehr von der
Welt erwartet von unserer
Bundesregierung was diese klaren Signale
angeht kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch
drauf ich wollte nur zurückkommen auf
die Diplomatie Herr macron wird morgen
mit Herrn Putin telefonieren macron war
Anfang der Woche hier bei Olaf Scholz
und man hat gesagt also Putin wenn du da
einmarschiert das wird mächtige
Konsequenzen haben auch wirtschaftliche
Art das klingt von außen immer so ein
bisschen wie die Drohung mit ja mit was
was passiert dann
es wird einen hohen Preis geben für
Russland im Falle einer militärischen
Aggression und eins müssen wir einfach
nochmal festhalten Russland ist in dem
Konflikt in der obstukraine nicht
Vermittler sondern Partei ostern steht
auf der Seite der Aggressoren die
Separatisten in der Ostukraine könnten
ohne militärische und finanzielle und
auch politische Unterstützung Moskaus
gar nicht sich halten und deshalb kommt
es jetzt auf die Vermittlungsbemühungen
von Deutschland und Frankreich das sind
die beiden Vermittler in dem
normandie-format an und deshalb ist
diese Abstimmung zwischen macron und
Scholz so existenziell auch für die
Sicherheit der Ukraine die Sanktionen
die auf dem Tisch liegen sind sehr breit
und es ist gut dass Putin sich nicht
genau ausrechnen kann wenn ich das tue
passiert jenes deshalb geht es um
Sanktionen im Bereich der Energie
einschließlich des Stopps der Pipeline
Nord Stream 2 es geht um Banken und um
den Finanzsektor der sanktioniert werden
kann bis hin zum Ausschluss der ist
russischen der russischen Wirtschaft von
dem Zahlungssystem Swift es geht um
weitere sektorale Sanktionen zum
Beispiel um Hightech Güter und es geht
auch um persönliches Sanktionen der
Verantwortlichen in Moskau für den Fall
eine Aggression damit ist klar es wäre
eine enorme strategischer Preis von
Russland zu bezahlen und diese
abschreckungskulisse ist glaubwürdig und
eröffnet uns dann die Spielräume für
diplomatidia in den letzten Tagen zum
Glück größer geworden sind von einem
Sozialdemokraten so dahin gesagt Nord
Stream 2 gehört jetzt auch zu dem Paket
seit einigen Wochen auch für die
Sozialdemokratie sicherlich kein
leichter Weg aber für uns alle auch
nicht Herr hart weil diese
wirtschaftlichen Sanktionen das wird
immer so gesagt sind wir nicht doch
abhängig zum Beispiel von den
Gaslieferungen da gibt es ja schon Nord
Stream 1 und wir kriegen 55 Prozent
unseres Gases aus der aus Russland
können wir so einfach sagen ihr werdet
sanktioniert und
dann schneiden wir uns ins eigene
Fleisch am Schluss
Sanktionspolitik ist
wenn man darauf verzichten will
militärisch einzugreifen das einzige
Mittel mit dem wir Drucker ausüben
können und deswegen müssen wir im
Zweifel zu diesen Sanktionen stehen so
wie wir das ja im übrigen auch in
anderen Fragen nicht gegenüber Russland
aber also auch gegen Russland aber auch
gegenüber anderen Ländern gemacht haben
ich glaube aber dass wir als deutschen
schon klar darüber sein müssen wenn wir
jetzt nicht klare Kante zeigen und wenn
wir jetzt nicht klar bei unseren
Prinzipien bleiben und eben uns als
unerpressbar darstellen dann würden wir
früher oder später einen viel höheren
Preis bezahlen müssen das ist das große
Risiko was ich damit verbinden würde
wenn wir jetzt meinen das löst sich auf
meine mein Wunsch ist natürlich dass
dieser Konflikt sich diplomatisch
beilegen lässt und dann ist alles
möglich mit Russland neue
abrüstungsverhandlung vielleicht auch
eine verbindliche Zusage über
Stationierung von NATO-Truppen und
russischen Truppen im Grenzgebiet
zwischen Russland und NATO
langfristige gaslieferverträge alles
diese Dinge Einbeziehung Russland sind
eine Wirtschaftsordnung wir haben mal
den Plan gehabt eine Freihandelszone von
Lissabon bis Wladiwostok als Europäische
Union plus andere plus Russland das sind
alles Träume und Möglichkeiten die wir
erfüllen können wenn Russland das nur
will das ist unser Angebot was auf dem
Tisch liegt und dieses untermauert dass
Dialogangebot ganz besonders dass wir
also nicht nur im luftigen Raum
operieren sondern dass es konkrete
Vorschläge geht was man tun könnte auch
im Sinne des russischen Volkes Herr
Schmid ich habe gerade Helmut Schmidt am
Anfang zitiert in der Tat des verhandeln
besser als kämpfen dazu muss man auch
sozusagen die Position haben um zu
verhandeln man hat so ein bisschen das
Gefühl dass Wladimir Putin Angela Merkel
solange sie noch da war als
Verhandlungspartnerin sehr wohl
anerkannt hat osteuropäischen Ländern
ist es jetzt so dass die neue deutsche
Bundesregierung gewaltig unter Druck
gerät mit ihrer doch sehr klaren Haltung
zu Waffenlieferungen und gestern
natürlich der Vorfall die Ukraine hatte
gebeten um 100.000 Helm und Schutzwesten
und die verteilungsministerin hat 5000
Helme zur Verfügung gestellt schon
gesagt dass er ein ganz deutliches
Zeichen wir stehen an eurer Seite haben
Sie Verständnis dafür dass nicht nur die
Ukraine sondern auch viele
osteuropäische Staaten das als hohen
empfinden ich habe Verständnis für den
Wunsch der Ukraine nach militärischer
Sicherheit und auch nach Unterstützung
in dieser Lage deshalb
wird es zu Recht diskutiert bloß für uns
kommen gerade weil wir eine
Vermittlerrolle in dem normandie-format
zusammen mit Frankreich
eingeräumt bekommen haben kommen
Waffenlieferung nicht in Frage weil das
würde ja diese Vermittlungsbemühungen
die wir gerade in Gang gesetzt haben
untergraben dass wir die Ukraine
vielfältig wirtschaftlich und finanziell
unterstützen und das auch noch bereit
sind auszubauen weil ja die
Wirtschaftslage nur keine auch leitet
und der der jetzigen Situation und
Bedrohung das ist völlig klar das werden
wir auch weiter tun und wir bitten
unsere ukrainischen Freunde deshalb auch
um Verständnis dass wir bei der einen
Frage vielleicht nicht ganz so viel
leisten können wie Sie es wünschen aber
in anderen Bereichen viel mehr tun als
alle anderen denn wir wollen dass die
Ukraine als selbstständiges Land
europäisches Land seinen eigenen Weg
gehen kann und alles was wir mit
Russland besprechen darf eben die
Souveränität nicht nur der Ukraine
sondern auch unsere solchen
osteuropäischen Partnern nicht in Frage
stellen was besonders wichtig wäre wäre
das wir zu einer Verabredung in Europa
über die Begrenzung der konventionellen
Streitkräfte und Truppen kommen das
würde die Bedrohungslage auch gerade
zwischen Russland und den Nachbarstaaten
deutlich reduzieren das wäre glaube ein
wichtiger Verhandlungsgegenstand für die
kommenden Gesprächen keine
Waffenlieferung in die Ukraine das hat
auch die alte Regierung immer vertreten
auch der Außenpolitiker Jürgen Hardt vor
zwei Tagen habe ich ein Interview
gelesen da haben sie ihre Meinung
verändert ist es ja so dass die
Franzosen die Briten Waffenlieferungen
Aussicht stellen wenn es denn losgeht im
Moment haben sie das ja auch noch nicht
getan die deutschen sagen radikal wir
liefern keine Waffen sie haben jetzt
ihre Meinung verändert warum
wir haben diese Position der damaligen
großen Koalition seit 2014 durchgetragen
weil wie immer der Meinung waren die
militärische
eskalationsdominanz also dass die
Möglichkeit des militäre zu eskalieren
liegt bei Russland und wir würden durch
eine Aufrüstung der Ukraine im Zweifel
da nur einen Anreiz leisten jetzt
stellen wir leider fest seit spätestens
Anfang letzten Jahres das Russland diese
Signale völlig missdeutet und
seinerseits massiv an der russischen
ukrainischen Grenze aufrüstet und
Truppen zusammenzieht das ist eine
völlig veränderte Lage und ich finde es
ziemlich zügig wenn wir den Menschen in
der Ukraine sagen ihr habt zwar unseren
warmen Händedruck aber wenn das ganz
konkret darum geht euch zu schützen dann
helfen wir euch nicht deswegen finde ich
das defensiv Waffen Anforderungen der
Ukraine sorgfältig geprüft werden müssen
es muss immer geprüft werden es sind das
Waffen die Russland als Bedrohung für
Russland empfinden muss das würde ich
ausschließen aber das was rein Defensive
sollte man machen und Robert Habeck hat
vor noch nicht einmal acht Monaten in
der Ukraine gesagt den Wunsch nach
defensivwaffen dem könnte man wohl
schwerlich widersprechen und jetzt ist
er Vizekanzler und für Rüstungsexporte
zuständiger Bundesminister und er kann
sich in der Regierung mit dieser
Position offensichtlich nicht
durchsetzen nein weil die Linke bei den
Grünen aber auch bei der SPD das
blockiert aber es wird sicherlich nicht
entschieden werden durch deutsche
Waffenlieferungen Herr Schmied das ist
ein ärgerlicher Faktor weil die deutsche
Außenpolitik damit so ein bisschen auch
in diskreditiert wird Olaf Scholz reißt
jetzt im kommenden Monat erstmalig ich
glaube am 7 Februar nach Amerika und die
amerikanische Administration sie hält ja
noch voll zu Deutschland zumindest
offiziell und sagt wir sind da sehr
zufrieden wenn es darauf ankommt werden
auch die deutschen springen wie wichtig
ist diese deutsch-amerikanische Achse
für das Problem also für uns und auch
für Kanzler Scholz ist diese
transatlantische Freundschaft von
Partnerschaft des Rückgrat europäisch
und deutscher Sicherheit auch natürlich
unsere Mitarbeit und Mitwirkungen in der
NATO wir haben gerade auch in den
letzten Wochen bewiesen dass wir unseren
Verpflichtungen in der NATO voll
Nachkommen wir haben
zugesagt dass zusätzliche Flugzeuge die
Ostflanke der NATO in Rumänien absichern
und deshalb ist dieser Besuch der
Antrittsbesuch von Kanzler Scholz ein
ganz wichtiges Ereignis und
unterstreicht noch mal dass auch wenn im
normandie-format es erstmal auf
Deutschland und Frankreich ankommt wir
uns auf die Unterstützung der Amerikaner
zur Deeskalation in der Ukraine
verlassen können denn der beste Schutz
für die Ukraine ist ein Erfolg dieser
diplomatischen Bemühungen ja da will ich
noch mal nachfragen diplomatische
Bemühungen wie kann es denn jetzt
weitergehen der Ball liegt bei Herrn
Putin was vermuten sie mit ihrer
Erfahrung wird ja den Ball noch mal
aufnehmen und tatsächlich versuchen
Waffen dort aus in der aus der Nähe
seines Bereiches der NATO zu verbannen
sozusagen sich selber zurückziehen dass
als Faust fand und damit einen Erfolg
einheimsen oder ist er wirklich schon so
weit und sagt die sind alle so schwach
wir marschieren mal da eben in den
Donbass ein ich hoffe das nicht ich
glaube dass auch Putin kein Interesse
daran haben kann an einer militärischen
Lösung dieses Konflikts ich glaube auch
das wäre der Anfang vom Ende seiner
Herrschaft weil es enorm teuer ist weil
das auch ein enormes Risiko für Russland
und die russischen Streitkräfte wäre und
für die Isolation Russlands natürlich
auch ein ein wichtiger Punkt Russland
hätte große Schwierigkeiten
wirtschaftlich und politisch sich von
einer solchen völkerrechtswidrigen
Aktion zu erholen also insofern glaube
ich dass er schon weiß wie hoch der
Preis ist ich setze dabei diesen ganzen
Prozess auf das normandie-format und bei
der Kontrolle und Überwachung und
Umsetzung auch bei der Frage der Wahlen
in den entsprechenden umstrittenen
Gebieten setze ich darauf dass die OSZE
wieder stärker eine Rolle nimmt also die
Organisation für Sicherheit in Europa in
denen ja die Amerikaner und die Kanadier
also Nordamerika auch Mitglied sind und
eines entscheidende Rolle spielen aber
das hat ja Herr lavrow eigentlich in
Abrede gestellt der Außenminister hat
gesagt dass Normandie Format ist gut der
Kontakt zu den Amerikanern ist gut an
Europa und an der O Idee hat er keinen
kein Interesse er glaubt nicht dass
diese Verhandlung zu etwas führen weil
so viele Stimmen dort miteinander dann
sich erstmal koordinieren müssen in der
Tat die es normandie-format in 14 Tagen
in Berlin ist vielleicht das Format was
den Krieg noch verhindern kann zumindest
für die nächsten 14 Tage oder sehen Sie
das anders also es kommt erstmal auf das
nochmal die Format an das ist richtig
weil wenn es um den Waffenstillstand
geht beispielsweise müssen wir im
normandieformat konkrete Verabredungen
treffen wenn es um humanitäre Lösungen
für die Bevölkerung in den besetzten
Gebieten und in der Grenze der zur
kontaktlinie geht dann kommt es auf das
normandieformat an allerdings hat die
OSZE eine wichtige unterstützende Rolle
sie ist die einzige internationale
Organisation die in dem Gebiet tätig ist
mit einer Beobachtungsmission leider
wird sie immer wieder behindert auch von
den Separatisten und es wäre wichtig
dass Sie diese Rolle voll ausüben kann
ich wollte der oscd das nicht absprechen
aber der Außenminister aus Russland tut
das Herr Lava er sagt er erwartet sich
da nichts das Gespräch mit den
Amerikanern was ja ansteht und das
Gespräch eben hier in ziehen das könnte
entscheiden meine Damen und Herren und
alle sind der Hoffnung dass die
Diplomatie noch nicht am Ende ist aber
wir sind jetzt am Ende hier mit unserem
Gespräch über diesen Punkt gleich
debattieren die Parlamentarier im
Parlament darüber vorher gibt es hier
noch wichtige Wahlen ich gebe rein
Bärbel Bars hat bereits Platz genommen
wird testfay Jesus als Nachfolgerin für
die Kollegin Katja Keul als
stellvertretendes Mitglied des
wahlprüfungsausschusses gewählt werden
stimmen Sie dem Zug das ist
offensichtlich der Fall und damit ist
die Kollegin
auwet-test Jesus als stellvertretendes
Mitglied des wahlprüfungsausschusses
gewählt herzlichen Glückwunsch
interfraktionell wurde vereinbart zu
Tagesordnungspunkt sieben Buchstabe b
die Ergänzung der Beschlussempfehlung
des Haushaltsausschusses zum
Nachtragshaushalt auf Drucksache 20 530
aufzusetzen von der Frist für den Beginn
der Beratungen soll soweit erforderlich
abgewichen werden ich sehe dazu auch
kein Widerspruch damit ist das so
beschlossen
ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 4a
bis 4e Wahlen zu den Gremien wir werden
nun drei Wahlen mit Stimmzetteln und
wahlausweis sowie zwei Wahlen mit
Handzeichen durchführen
wir kommen zunächst zur Wahl der
Mitglieder des Wahlausschusses für die
vom Deutschen Bundestag zu berufen den
Richter des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes
gemäß Paragraf 6 Absatz 2 des
bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetzes sowie
des Ausschusses für die Wahl der Richter
der obersten Gerichtshöfe des
bundesgemäß Paragraf 5 des Richter
Wahlgesetzes und die Wahl eines
Mitglieds des Gremiums gemäß Paragraph 3
des Bundes schuldenwesensgesetzes
ja meine Damen und Herren Yvonne mag was
hat natürlich in diesen Minuten hier den
Vorsitz die Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
Bärbel Basis logischerweise noch mit den
israelischen Gästen auf die brasiliale
Ebene in Stunden und jetzt geht es also
jetzt hier um die Wahl mehrere
Mitglieder für
den Wahlausschuss und die Wahl von
Julian ist Wahlausschusses für den
Verfassungsrichter
ist eine sehr wichtige Wahl die Richter
jedes der beiden Senate des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts werden ja je
zur Hälfte von Bundestag und vom
Bundesrat gewählt in Amerika zum
Beispiel ist das ganz anders da bestimmt
der Präsident alleine wer in das oberste
Richtergremium einziehen darf der
Bundestag wählt also nach den Regeln des
Verhältniswahlrechts ein Wahlausschuss
für die Richter des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts der aus zwölf
Mitgliedern des Bundestages besteht jede
Fraktion kann einen Vorschlag einbringen
ja und diese Mitglieder die
sind auch schon benannt und ich weiß
nicht ob sie gleich in der vorgelesen
werden
Frau mag was ist hier noch bei den
abstimmungsimpernserabilien dann kann
ich hier noch schnell sagen dass danach
die Wahlen noch weitergehen da geht es
nämlich um das Gremium für schuldenwesen
des Bundes und die Wahl von
Schriftführern und Schriftführern sowie
die Wahl des Gemeinsamen Ausschusses
wenn wir jeweils da sind werde ich Ihnen
sagen worum es genau geht und was die
Aufgabe der gewählten sein wird hier
also wie gesagt jetzt die Mitglieder die
letzten Endes dann die
Verfassungsrichter Berufen je zur Hälfte
Bundestag und die andere Hälfte dieser
Mitglieder des Gremiums kommen aus dem
Bundesrat
Farben rosa grün oder orange ein
Wahlumschlag gibt es diesmal nicht die
Wahlen finden offen statt sie können
Ihre stimmzette also offen an einem
Tisch oder auch in einer der Wahlkabinen
ankreuzen bevor sie die Stimmzettel in
eine der Wahlurnen werfen übergeben Sie
bitte den Schriftführern an den
Wahlurnen ihren wahlausweis und der
Nachweis der Teilnahme an der Wahl kann
nur durch die Abgabe des wahlausweises
auch erbracht werden
sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme 100
Minuten Zeit
und sind besetzt die Urnen sind
besetztürigkeit also die Schriftführerin
und Schriftführer haben ihre Plätze
eingenommen und somit eröffne ich die
Wahl
und in den nächsten 100 Minuten haben
Sie Zeit den Wahlgang vorzunehmen
bleiben Sie bitte aber noch einen Moment
im Saal da wir noch zwei Wahlen mittels
Handzeichen durchführen müssen
ist der Tagesordnungspunkt 4D die Wahl
der Schriftführerin und Schriftführer
gemäß Paragraph 3
der
Geschäftsordnung für die Wahl der
Schriftführerin und Schriftführer liegen
die Wahlvorschläge aller Fraktionen auf
Drucksache 5003 vor wer stimmt für diese
Wahlvorschläge
jetzt also eine sammelabstimmung über
die schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer
während die Wahl zum Richter
Wahlausschuss
dem Heimer Wahl mit Stimmkarte erfolgt
hier mit Handaufheben diese
Schriftführer sind übrigens sehr wichtig
sie sehen Sie immer rechts und links
neben der jeweiligen Präsidentin oder
den Präsidenten der gerade die Sitzung
geleitet die Schriftführer nehmen
nämlich Anträge und Wortmeldungen
entgegen verlesen Schriftstücke führen
rednerlisten überwachen die Korrekturen
des plenarprotokolls und stellen das
Ergebnis von Abstimmung fest und sie
helfen relativ häufig mal der
Präsidentin oder den Präsidenten
feststellen um welchen Abgeordneten sich
gerade handelt der zum Beispiel eine
Kurzintervention loswerden will und
diese Wahl ist jetzt schon gelaufen denn
die Fraktionen hatten bereits ihre
Kandidaten benannt übrigens die
afd-kandidaten hier in einer Liste
mitgewählt
Situationen auf Drucksache 504 vor wer
stimmt für diese Wahlvorschläge
wer stimmt dagegen
ja geht es um den gemeinsamen Ausschuss
der gemeinsamen Ausschuss ist eine Art
notparlament dass ich zu zwei Dritteln
aus Abgeordneten des Bundestages und zu
einem Drittel aus Vertretern der
Bundesländer zusammensetzt und eins
kommen wir tatsächlich dann schon zu der
Debatte über die Ukraine während eben
jetzt die Abgeordneten aufgerufen sind
die nächsten 100 Minuten ihre Wahlzettel
einzuwerfen für die Wahl der Mitglieder
des
Wahlausschusses für Verfassungsrichter
Minuten beschlossen
und als erster Rednerin erteile ich das
Wort der Bundesministerin Annalena
bärburg Annalena bärburg hat ja ihre
erste Reise dann auch nach Paris gemacht
dann war sie in der Ukraine zunächst und
dann erst in Moskau das ist sehr
aufgefallen und war ein positiver Zug
der deutschen Bundesregierung was gerade
die Ukraine angeht das wurde da auch
sehr registriert in den letzten Tagen
war man allerdings sehr unzufrieden mit
der deutschen Politik vor allem auch in
der Ukraine aktuell eine Zeit die für
Frieden und Sicherheit auf unserem
Kontinent entscheidend ist eine Zeit in
der wir für unsere Werte eintreten
müssen eine Zeit in der markige Sprüche
gut klingen aber Steilvorlagen für
heftigste Konsequenzen sein könnten
das ist alles andere als eine einfache
politische Zeit denn es ist schwer es
nicht als Drohung zu verstehen wenn sich
über 100.000 Soldaten mit Panzern und
Geschützen ohne nachvollziehbare Gründe
in der Nähe der Ukraine versammeln und
in Belarus weitere Truppen
zusammengezogen werden und die russische
Regierung hat uns mit Forderung nach
sogenannten Sicherheitsgarantien
konfrontiert die mit der europäischen
sicherheitsordnung nicht vereinbar sind
die Bundesregierung reagiert darauf
geschlossen und entschlossen und ehrlich
gesagt nicht was uns gerade so einfällt
sondern natürlich in enger Abstimmung
gemeinsam mit unseren EU-Partnern
unseren NATO-Partnern im Rahmen der G7
und da haben wir klipp und klar deutlich
gemacht dass ein erneutes militärisches
Vorgehen gegen die Ukraine massive
Konsequenzen für Russland hätte auf
dieser Basis arbeiten wir an einem
starken Sanktionspaket bei neuer
Aggression steht die Bandbreite unserer
Antworten zur Verfügung inklusive
northstream 2 ja wir wollen jederzeit
Dialog aber es braucht angesichts der
aktuellen Lage auch Härte die
unmissverständlich deutlich macht die
souveräne Gleichheit von Staaten und die
Grundpfeiler der europäischen
Friedensordnung sind nicht verhandelbar
diese Haltung vertreten wir geschlossen
und zwar transatlantisch und europäisch
in den vergangenen Wochen ist kein
einziger Tag vergangen an dem ich nicht
mit den amtskolleginnen und Amtskollegen
aus der EU und aus der NATO gesprochen
habe in zahlreichen Telefonaten und
persönlichen Treffen dabei hatte ich
genauso wie der Bundeskanzler zwei
Botschaften unsere Einigkeit ist unsere
stärkste Waffe wenn man dieses Wort
überhaupt gebrauchen möchte und ja das
kann man ganz offen sagen unsere Rollen
sind dabei nicht komplett identisch wir
haben unterschiedliche Rollen zwischen
unterschiedlichen Ländern Länder wie
Polen und Litauen übernehmen eine andere
Rolle als Länder wie Italien Frankreich
und eben auch Deutschland und zwar aus
guten Gründen denn unsere Stärke in
diesem Bündnis ist doch gerade dass wir
eine klare gemeinsame Haltung haben und
zugleich unsere stärk in
unterschiedlichen Rollen entsprechend
einsetzen
um
[Applaus]
mal dümmerin die alle dasselbe machen
sondern elf Spielerinnen die gut
miteinander können und die vor allen
Dingen den gleichen gemeinsam Spielplan
im Kopf haben und unsere besondere Rolle
ist dabei als Deutschland als eins der
stärksten Wirtschafts- und
Industrienationen der Welt und führende
Rolle in Europa Deutschland ist seit
Jahren der größte Geber in der Ukraine
über den IWF über die EU und bilateral
aktuell arbeiten wir daran 150 Millionen
Euro aus einem ungebundenen finanzkredit
möglichst schnell an die Ukraine
auszuzahlen wir arbeiten natürlich bei
der impfstoffversorgung im Energiesektor
und bei den Reformprozessen im Land
gemeinsam mit unseren Partnern zusammen
und wir haben gemeinsam mit Frankreich
und es waren in den letzten Jahren nicht
immer einfach dafür gesorgt dass wir als
Europäerinnen und Europäer und gerade in
diesem Moment bei den Sanktionen ganz
eng beiein länger bleiben und
Deutschland
das braucht man gar nicht so
wegzuwischen Deutschland unterstützt die
Ukraine auch militärisch und zwar und
das möchte ich auch einmal deutlich
sagen an dieser Stelle auf ukrainischen
Wunsch liefern wir jetzt Schutzhelme
auch das hat sich Frau Lambrecht nicht
einfach ausgedacht sondern das war der
besondere Wunsch dem wir hier jetzt
Nachkommen das gleiche gilt für
Schutzbunker bei Odessa da gab es den
Anruf vor ein paar Tagen dass wir bitte
unterstützen wollen die wir wieder
instand zu setzen und morgen weil wir
direkt handeln wird eine erste
Erkundungsreise dahin stattfinden
ukrainische Offiziere haben an der
militärischen Ausbildungshilfe des
Bundesverteidigungsministeriums
teilgenommen deutsche Unterstützung für
die Ukraine im Rahmen des NATO
Treuhandfonds beträgt mehr als 8
Millionen Euro seit 2014 auch und das
wird gerade vorbereitet in der EU planen
wir jetzt gemeinsam mit den anderen
europäischen Partnern eine
ausbildungsunterstützung für die Ukraine
im nato-bündnis aber hier ist es wichtig
dass wir das Unterscheiden zwischen der
Unterstützung der Ukraine und im
nato-bündnis ist Deutschland seit 2014
eine der leitnationen in der vorne
Präsenz im Baltikum genauso stehen wir
auch heute zu unserer Verantwortung im
Bündnis dass wir in diesem Jahr wieder
mit der Beteiligung an der NATO eher
policing-faus in Rumänien und in
Baltikum aktiv sind
meine Damen und Herren auch darüber
diskutieren wir heute sehr offen weil
das ist ja Sinn und Zweck einer
parlamentarischen Debatte nun fordern
einige diesen Kurs zu verlassen und
jetzt akut Waffen zu liefern natürlich
und das sage ich auch ganz offen und
ehrlich muss man in schwierigen
Situationen sein Handeln immer wieder
auch selbstkritisch reflektieren aber
ich sage hier auch sehr klar und
deutlich da ich ja nicht nur Chef
Diplomatin unseres Landes bin sondern
auch PolitikerInnen eine
Pressemitteilung ist schnell geschrieben
aber sein außenpolitischen Kurs einfach
mal so um 180 Grad zu drehen wo gerade
noch sage ich auch an die Unionsfraktion
im Sommer eine andere Entscheidung
getroffen worden ist das sollte man
schon bei vollem Bewusstsein tun und vor
allen Dingen damit nicht Türen für die
Eskalation verschließen die sich gerade
in diesem Moment so zaghaft wieder
öffnen
und ich war ja ich war ja in der letzten
Woche bewusst vor Ort und darüber zu
sprechen sowohl in der Ukraine als auch
in Russland und Präsident selensky hat
gestern noch mal deutlich gemacht wie
wichtig für ihn minzig dass er ein
baldiges Gipfeltreffen dringend dringend
sich wünscht und das ist Fortschritte im
Verhandlungsprozess braucht und das hat
für mich das hat für diese
Bundesregierung jetzt absolut oberste
Priorität
gestern hat deswegen zum ersten Mal seit
langem und auch das sah ist keine
Selbstverständlichkeit wieder ein
physisches Berater Treffen im
normandie-format stattgefunden wir haben
über 8 Stunden lang dort verhandelt ob
da was bei rauskommt wir wissen es nicht
niemand kann das in dieser Zeit
hundertprozentig sagen aber wer redet
der schießt nicht daher ist es fatal die
Wiederaufnahme von Dialog jetzt einfach
so abzutun und warum weil seit zwei
Jahren die Menschen im dornbas in dieser
Pandemie noch mal ganz besonders leiden
und das minsker-abkommen das dreht sich
ja gerade darum den Menschen in der
Region die zum Teil als ich da war hat
eine botschaftsmitarbeiterin gesagt ich
bin immer mal wieder hingefahren um
meine kranke Oma zu sehen aber seitdem
ich jetzt ein kleines Baby habe mache
ich das nicht mehr was ist wenn ich
nicht mehr zurückkomme das sind die
Lebensschicksale um die es hier geht das
ist die Alltagssituation für viele viele
tausende von Menschen und deswegen ist
das minsker-abkommen so entscheidend
wir werden daher und ich komme zum
Schluss frau Präsidentin wir werden
daher mein französischer Amtskollege
ludrian und ich übernächste Woche wieder
in die Ukraine auch an die kontaktlinie
reisen um gerade auch die intensiven
Bemühungen der OSZE an dieser Stelle zu
unterstützen und ich sage sehr sehr
deutlich das was wir gerade tun
wirtschaftlich in der Zusammenarbeit das
ist essentiell in dieser Situation wir
müssen in diesem Moment die Ukraine
gerade wirtschaftlich und finanziell
stärken denn im 21 Jahrhundert da
bedroht man nicht nur mit Kanonen
sondern wir haben noch in der Pandemie
gesehen was passiert wenn Lieferketten
ausfallen und deswegen haben wir habe
ich ganz bewusst entschieden dass wir
nicht unser Botschaftspersonal
reduzieren sondern dass wir die Ukraine
dadurch unterstützen dass wir präsent
sind dass wir investieren dass
Diplomatie absoluten Vorrang hat und
dass wir die gemeinsam für die
Sicherheit der Ukraine und den Europa
eintreten herzlichen Dank
die Shift Diplomat in Deutschlands
Anna-Lena bärbock die deutsche
Außenministerin hat hier noch einmal die
deutsche Außenpolitik verteidigt
Vorrang der Diplomatie dem würde
sicherlich keiner widersprechen das
Auftreten an der ein oder anderen Stelle
der deutschen Bundesregierung aber das
wirkt für viel Kritik im Ausland auch
die Helm Lieferung gestern 5000 Helme
das hat er für Sport gesorgt und jetzt
erhält hier Friedrich Merz das Wort er
ist ja gewählt worden als neuer CDU-Chef
wird aber dieses Amt offiziell erst ab
dem 31 Januar begleiten
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wir
stehen vermutlich
alle noch unter dem Eindruck der reden
die wir heute morgen
zum Jahrestag der Befreiung des
Konzentrationslagers Auschwitz
gehört haben
und es erfüllt mich mit etwas Beklemmung
wenige Minuten später
hier im Deutschen Bundestag reden zu
müssen über die Frage
ob da nicht möglicherweise erneut ein
Krieg droht in Europa ein Krieg vor
Werbung kein Fußballspiel
und der Bundeskanzler wir hätten uns
durchaus vorstellen können dass nicht
die Bundestagsfraktion auf unsere
Initiative hin heute morgen hier diese
Debatte beantragen
sondern dass sie als Bundeskanzler der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu dieser
Lage eine Regierungserklärung abgeben
und anschließend eine Debatte im
Deutschen Bundestag stattfinden
es droht ein Krieg in einem Teil unseres
Kontinents der von den Verbrechen des
Zweiten Weltkrieges in besonders
brutaler Weise
betroffen war
auf dem Territorium der heutigen Ukraine
hat es grausame Verbrechen an der
Zivilbevölkerung gegeben vor allem an
der jüdischen Bevölkerung
die Ukraine hat allein im Zweiten
Weltkrieg mehr als ein Viertel ihrer
Bevölkerung verloren und schon vor dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg war die Ukraine
vielfältig Opfer
der russischen Bürgerkriege der
Kollektivierung unter Stalin und nicht
zuletzt des Hitler stalin-paktes von
deswegen Frau baerbock erlaube ich mir
schon den Hinweis wenn sie an anderer
Stelle mit Verweis auf die deutsche
Geschichte
zur Rücksichtnahme und zur Zurückhaltung
erahnen die wir teilen dann geht das
nicht nur an die Adresse Russlands dann
geht das auch und ganz besonders an die
Adresse der Ukraine ich denke wir müssen
deshalb heute zunächst einmal
einige Dinge miteinander klären wir sind
uns vermutlich hier im Deutschen
Bundestag weitgehend einig das Russland
ein europäisches Land ist dass wir alle
gern als Teil einer dauerhaften
politischen Ordnung in Europa sehen
würden und ich will persönlich
hinzufügen die meisten von uns haben in
Erinnerung die Rede die Wladimir Putin
von dieser Stelle aus wenige Tage nach
9/11 im Jahr 2001 fast ausschließlich in
deutscher Sprache vor dem Deutschen
Bundestag gehalten hat
ich habe diese Rede hier im Parlament
miterlebt und ich sage ganz ausdrücklich
ich bedauere dass die damalige
Bundesregierung Gerhard Schröder
die Angebote die Putin gemacht hat nicht
angenommen hat und ich bedauere dass ich
als Oppositionsführer im Jahr 2001 die
Bundesregierung Gerhard Schröder vier
Wochen später nicht gefragt habe warum
war dieser Angebote
nicht angenommen hat aber meine Damen
und Herren das war der Putin von 2001
diejenigen von Ihnen die an der
Sicherheitskonferenz im Jahr 2007 in
München teilgenommen haben wissen dass
wir seit dem Jahr 2007 einen anderen
Putin haben
und dieser Putin und dieses Russland
destabilisiert systematisch seit 15
Jahren die politische Ordnung in Europa
und dies unter beständiger Verletzung
der Verträge und Vereinbarungen die
Russland und zuvor die Sowjetunion
verbindlich eingegangen sind
Cyberangriffe auf den Deutschen
Bundestag
Auftragsmorde und Giftanschläge im
eigenen Land und den anderen Ländern
Europas bis hin zu der als Tiergarten
Mord in die Öffentlichkeit gelangten
Ermordung eines Georgias hier in
unmittelbarer Nähe wenige hundert Meter
vom Deutschen Bundestag entfernt im
Tiergarten das sind der tägliche Bestand
des Handelns des russischen Staates
vorrangiges Ziel der permanenten
Destabilisierung durch Russland ist ganz
offensichtlich seit einigen Jahren die
Ukraine erst die völkerrechtswidrige
Annexion der Krim zugleich das
Eindringen russischer Truppen und
paramilitärischer Einheiten in die
Ostukraine und seit einigen Wochen nun
ein massiver Truppenaufmarsch an
mehreren Stellen auch in Belarus im
Zangenangriff auf die gesamte Ukraine
meine Damen und Herren ich hoffe dass
wir uns hier im Deutschen Bundestag in
der Feststellung einig sind dass diese
Gefährdung des Friedens in Europa
ausschließlich von der Russischen
Föderation und ausschließlich von
Vladimir Putin ausgeht
und deshalb
Herr Bundeskanzler
sagen wir Ihnen trotz der sehr unklaren
Position zu Russland die offensichtlich
in ihrer eigenen Partei auch ihr Handeln
bestimmt nicht allein wie ihr die
Opposition im Deutschen Bundestag die
Menschen in unserem Land erwarten von
Ihnen jetzt dass sie im deutschen
Parlament eine klare Einschätzung der
Lage aus ihrer Sicht geben und dass sie
vor allem die Konsequenzen daraus für
Deutschland und für Europa aufzeigen wir
erwarten von Ihnen dass Sie so wie alle
ihre Vorgänger im Amt des Bundeskanzlers
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
Initiativen ergreifen mit Partnern in
der Europäischen Union und wenn es nicht
alle 27 sein können und sein wollen dann
wenigstens mit Frankreich mit Polen mit
den baltischen Staaten auch mit
Großbritannien hier gemeinsame klare
Antworten zu geben dies erfordert eine
klare und
unzweifelhaltehaftehaltung der Regierung
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland meine
Damen und Herren
es kann
es kann sein dass wir noch etwas Zeit
haben
aber dann Herr Bundeskanzler darf an der
europäischen und dann darf auch an der
deutschen Entschlossenheit kein Zweifel
entstehen und diese Zweifel sind da sie
haben es immerhin fertig gebracht in dem
ansonsten heillos zerstrittenen
amerikanischen Kongress eine
vollkommenheitliche Einschätzung des
unklaren Bildes und der
Unzuverlässigkeit der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland entstehen zu lassen und das
ist ihre Verantwortung der Bundeskanzler
das ist ihre Politik sie führen nicht
weder in Deutschland noch in Europa
und wer wie sie
und wer wie sie diese Zweifel entstehen
lässt sich erkennbar jedenfalls für die
deutsche Öffentlichkeit es kann ja sein
dass sie im Stillen viel Gutes tun aber
wir erkennbar sich um dieses Problem zu
wenig kümmert der vergrößert das Risiko
nicht nur für die Bevölkerung in der
Ukraine sondern auch für die politische
Stabilität in ganz Europa
Friedrich Merz hat hier Olaf Scholz
vorgehalten dass er zum einen hier keine
Regierungserklärung zu diesem wichtigen
Thema abgehalten hat sondern die
Fraktionen diese Debatte beantragen
musste dass er keine klare Haltung
zurück keine Krise erkennen lässt und
keine klare Führung aushöhe
bemerkenswert das Friedrich Merz hier
der erste Redner sein durfte und der
Fraktionschef ihm dieses Rederecht
eingeräumt hat die Union muss ja noch
klären wie das zwischen den beiden
Männern in Zukunft laufen soll aber
immerhin auch die SPD stellt ihren
Parteichef auf nämlich Lars Klingbeil
hier als nächsten Redner
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
die Bundesregierung ist gestartet in
einer schwierigen internationalen
Situation wir hatten noch nicht mal die
Tinte trocken unter dem
Koalitionsvertrag als die neue Regierung
schon gefordert war mit nicht nur einer
schwierigen innenpolitischen Lage und
der Pandemie sondern auch mit einer
schwierigen außenpolitischen Lage und
dem sich zuspitzenden Konflikt an der
russisch-ukrainischen Grenze umzugehen
und ich will meine Rede damit beginnen
dass ich den Bundeskanzler und der
bundesaußenministerin danke für das
Engagement und die Intensität des
Engagements die beide stellvertretend
für die ganze Bundesregierung in den
letzten Wochen an den Tag gelegt haben
ist es wichtig dass Deutschland
internationale europäische Verantwortung
übernimmt das erleben wir von dieser
Bundesregierung dafür ein großer Dank an
dieser Stelle
und Herr Merz
Glückwunsch an dieser Stelle noch mal
zur Wahl
ich sage genau ich habe mich gefragt wie
lange diese ruhige bedächtige Tonlage
die wir in den letzten Wochen von ihnen
erlebt haben wie lange die anhält und
Sie haben Recht aus dem Politik ist kein
Fußballspiel ich sage auch Außenpolitik
ist mehr als schwarz-weiß aus dem
Politik hat nicht diese simple
Einteilung in gut und böse
ich habe aber auch eine Bitte
Außenpolitik dient auch nicht der
Selbstfindung einer neuen
Oppositionspartei ich glaube
ich glaube
dass die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
immer geprägt war davon dass wir ein
Konsens hatten in der
außensicherheitspolitik der größer war
als eine Regierungsmehrheit und ich
wünsche mir und diesen Wunsch möchte ich
äußern dass wir das beibehalten
ich habe mich gefragt auch gerade in
ihrer Rede und auch in den letzten Tagen
wenn man einige Kommentare hört was
wünscht man sich eigentlich an der
Spitze des Landes wir hatten eine
Bundeskanzlerin die 16 Jahre und ich
will dass hier erwähnen das Land gut
geführt hat indem Sie Lösungen gefunden
hat aber nicht auf überschriftengesetze
und das ist auch das was ich jetzt von
einer Bundesregierung erwartet me es
gibt andere Beispiele ein konservativer
Staatslenker in Großbritannien der die
Europäische Union kaputt macht ein
konservativer und Freund der gerade der
CSU in Ungarn mit Herrn Orban der die
Europäische Union kaputt macht ein ich
erinnere mich daran wie die Junge Union
damals die Wahl von Herrn Trump als
konservativen Staatslenker gefeiert hat
der auf Überschriften gesetzt hat aber
internationale Beziehung kaputt gemacht
hat Herr Merz das worum es geht ist doch
dass wir hier eine Bundesregierung haben
die mit Bedacht und lösungsorientiert
eine schwierige Lage wie wir sein der
russisch-ukrainischen Grenze haben die
dort Lösungen sucht und das ist das was
ich von einer Bundesregierung erwarte
und deswegen nochmal ein großer Dank an
Olaf Scholz an Annalena vielen Dank für
das was wir in den letzten Wochen erlebt
und worauf kommt es jetzt an
ich will ein paar Punkte hier klar
benennen das erste ist und das müssen
wir uns jeden Tag bewusst machen mitten
in Europa droht gerade ein Krieg zwei
Flugstunden von Berlin Weg droht eine
kriegerische Auseinandersetzung die
diesen Kontinent nachhaltig verändern
kann und deswegen geht es nicht um eine
innenpolitische Debatte es geht darum
aus politisch alles jetzt zu tun damit
eine militärische Eskalation der Lage
abgewandt werden kann zweiter Punkt um
den es geht und da bin ich völlig klar
und da sage ich in aller Deutlichkeit
wir benennen sehr deutlich von wem die
Eskalation ausgeht das ist die russische
Seite die Eskalation die wir erleben
geht gerade von Russland aus und wir
blicken mit großer Sorge auf die
völkerrechtswidrige Annektion der Krim
auf innenpolitische Entwicklung in
Russland die Verletzung des Völkerrechts
wir sind da klar wenn die territoriale
Integrität der Ukraine angegriffen wird
dann gibt es eine klare eine konsequente
und eine entschiedene Antwort die diese
Bundesregierung mit den internationalen
Partnern abgestimmt hat
und Herr Merz ich weiß gar nicht was
unverständlich ist an der Aussage des
Bundeskanzlers alle Option liegen auf
dem Tisch ich meine es waren nicht der
Vorsitzende der FDP oder die Vorsitzende
der Grünen oder der SPD die als erstes
gerufen haben nee aber Swift nehmen wir
raus das waren sie sie haben der
russischen Seite gezeigt dass wir dort
wackeln an dieser Stelle und der Satz
alle Optionen liegen auf dem Tisch der
muss von allen hier unterschrieben
werden und das ist mein dritter Punkt
wir brauchen Klarheit und wir brauchen
Konsequenz wenn die russische Seite die
Grenze politisch geografisch
überschreitet aber bis dahin bis dahin
konzentrieren wir uns doch jetzt bitte
darauf über Frieden zu reden wir
brauchen doch nicht jeden Tag Drohung
wir brauchen nicht jeden Tag Droge
werden wir brauchen nicht jeden Tag eine
weitere Eskalation der Situation sondern
wir machen deutlich als Bundesrepublik
Deutschland das ist gerade darum geht
Frieden zu organisieren jedes Gespräch
zu nutzen jeden Dialog jeden Tisch an
denen man sich setzen kann ist wichtig
damit Frieden organisiert wird und ich
sage hier ausdrücklich Waffen zu liefern
bedeutet nicht Friedensbemühungen zu
stärken und deswegen ganz klar wir
liefern keine Waffen in die Ukraine
und der letzte Punkt
der letzte Punkt den ich ansprechen will
ja wenn die aktuelle Situation
überwunden ist müssen wir auch wieder
die größere Perspektive spannen eine
dauerhafte Friedensordnung in Europa
wird es nicht geben gegen Russland
sondern nur mit Russland und deswegen
muss der russischen Seite klar
signalisiert werden ihr habt euch der
verrannt ihr seid auf einem völlig
falschen Weg das was ihr gerade tut
rückt diese europäische Friedensordnung
in weite fern aber das Angebot sich an
den Tisch zu setzen und darüber zu reden
wie wir Frieden und Stabilität in Europa
organisieren dieses Angebot bleibt
bestehen herzlichen Dank
Lars Klingbeil der SPD-Parteivorsitzende
lobte hier die klare Führung der
Bundesregierung namentlich des Kanzlers
und der Außenministerin und hat auch
noch mal unterstrichen dass Deutschland
der Mittler sein könnte jetzt gibt es
eine kurze Intervention gleich für
Friedrich Merz
die Melnik herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
lauscht dieser Debatte und Friedrich
Merz jetzt mit einer Kurzintervention
Herr Kollege klingball wir nehmen das
Angebot einer
weitestmöglichen Zusammenarbeit in der
Außenpolitik in der Sicherheitspolitik
in der Verteidigungspolitik mit ihrer
Bundesregierung ihrer Fraktion den
Koalitionsfraktionen an und damit genau
an dieser Stelle keine Irritationen
entstehen ich habe Swift in der Tat
angesprochen ich habe um im Bild zu
bleiben was ich gewählt habe auf die
Sprengkraft hingewiesen die eine
Aussetzung von SWIFT bedeuten würde aber
es liegt auch für mich ausdrücklich mit
auf dem Tisch der Möglichkeiten wenn es
darum geht diese Bedrohung abzuwenden
nicht nur für die Ukraine sondern für
ganz Europa es ist nicht vom Tisch es
bleibt auf dem Tisch es hat allerdings
erhebliche Rückwirkungen auch auf unsere
Volkswirtschaft und die müssen wir alle
Bedenken wenn wir auch über solche
Instrumente sprechen
[Applaus]
und ich erteile das Wort dem nächsten
Redner Stefan Keuter afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren lassen sie uns zusammen
eine Zeitreise in das Jahr 1962 machen
der damalige amerikanische Präsident
Kennedy drohte der Sowjetunion mit einem
Dritten Weltkrieg sollten Sie atomare
Waffen auf Kuba quasi vor der Haustüre
der USA stationieren und wenn Sie mich
fragen tat er das zurecht warum tat er
das es waren die Sicherheitsinteressen
der Vereinigten Staaten massiv bedroht
lassen Sie uns einmal 30 Jahre
weitergehen ca 30 Jahre ins Jahr 1999
Polen Tschechien und Ungarn treten der
NATO bei etwa fünf Jahre später 2004
folgten Bulgarien Estland Lettland
Litauen Rumänien die Slowakei und
Slowenien betrachten wir einmal das
Verhältnis zwischen der Russischen
Föderation und der Ukraine es ist in der
Post sowjetischen Zeit geprägt durch
Scharmützel um Gas-
[Musik]
ansprechen 180 Jahre war sie Russisch
nachdem sie von den Osmanen erobert
wurde wurde russifiziert und 1954 hat
großstoff aus einem Verwaltungsakt des
ging damals um den Bau einer
Eisenbahnlinie die Krim der Ukraine
angegliedert die Krim hat seitdem
zweimal versucht zu Russland
zurückzukehren
1994 und zuletzt 2014 in einem
Referendum wo über 7 über 96,97 Prozent
der Bevölkerung der Krim für den
Anschluss am Russland stimmte
völkerrechtlich gibt es da verschiedene
Bewertungsmöglichkeiten aber der wird
unsere Außenministerin uns ja
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr zu
sagen können was mich beängstigt ist
diese Stimmungsmache gegen Russland und
zwar in den Medien in der Politik und
vor allen Dingen auch hier in diesem
Hohen Hause den Bundestag wir müssen nur
unseren Vorrednern zugehört haben dann
sehen wir dass es sich um eine
unsägliche
rhetorikhandel um droh-szenarien von
Krieg und Einstellung von Gaslieferungen
in dieses verstößt auch der der
Botschafter Melnik der Ukraine der heute
in diesem Hause zu Gast ist das freut
mich Herr Mail nicht so kann ich Ihnen
auch sagen die Forderung nach Waffen
können wir Deutschen nicht erfüllen und
ihre unsägliche Kriegstreiberei kann ich
nur verurteilen sie beleidigen
Deutschland sie ziehen sie ziehen
unwürdige Vergleiche der deutschen
Geschichte zum Nutzen
Nationalsozialismus Frau bärbock unter
ihren Vorgängern wer so ein Botschafter
ins Auswärtige Amt eingestellt worden
und ein Staatssekretär hätte ein sehr
nachhaltiges Gespräch mit ihm geführt
es gibt aber auch andere Töne
Vizeadmiral Schönbach äußerte verkürze
das Russland Respekt auf Augenhöhe
möchte und auch verdienen würde das
Krieg absoluter nonsent sei und dass die
Krim weg ist und auch nie wieder
zurückkommen wird ich sage Sie meine
Damen und Herren diese Offizier hat
nicht nur recht er hat auch schneit
wem nutzt diese Eskalation an der Grenze
in der Ukraine fujono die USA nutzen die
Pipeline nord-steam 2 als Druckmittel
Deutschland soll eigene Interessen für
fremde Interessen
opfern wir schauen uns die eu-sanktion
von 2014 an die übrigens ganz geschickt
die USA ausklammern Leidtragen sind vor
allen Dingen Russland mit einem
wirtschaftsverlust von 36 Milliarden
US-Dollar und direkt gefolgt von
Deutschland mit weitem Abstand zu allen
anderen europäischen Staaten zusammen 23
Milliarden US-Dollar wir schneiden uns
mit diesen Sanktionen ins eigene Fleisch
und das muss ein Ende haben die
US-Wirtschaft übrigens hat im gleichen
Zeitraum ein Plus in diesen Geschäften
gemacht damit muss Schluss sein die
Ukraine braucht eine Lösung eine Lösung
die sowohl auf der einen Seite die
Interessen der Ukraine berücksichtigt
auf der anderen Seite aber auch die
Sicherheitsinteressen der Russischen
Föderation wir haben es eben gehört und
da gebe ich Ihnen Recht einen ohne
Russland wird es nicht geben lassen mich
ein Fazit ziehen es gibt keinen Krieg es
droht auch kein Krieg das droht kein
gasmangel die Sicherheitsinteressen
Russlands müssen wir ernst nehmen dann
klappt das auch mit dem Weltfrieden
vielen Dank meine Damen und Herren
Stefan Kräuter von der AFD
ausdrücklich noch mal an die
parlamentarische Wortwahl erinnern und
auch hier im Hohen Hause eingehalten
wird vielen Dank
der nächste Redner ist Alexander Graf
Lambsdorff FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
Fraktionsvorsitzende für den Bereich
Außenpolitik der Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir führen hier eine Debatte
unter dem Titel Frieden in Europa
sichern
weil wir eine Kriegsgefahr in Europa
sehen die nach übereinstimmender Analyse
in diesem Haus mit Ausnahmen die nicht
weiter erheblich sind von Russland
ausgeht und ich möchte an diesem Tag am
27 Januar daran erinnern dass man den
Menschen in Russland
nichts über die Gräuel des Krieges
erzählen muss der 27 januar 1944 war der
Tag an dem die Rote Armee die Blockade
von Leningrad nach über 900 Tagen
Belagerung durch die deutsche Wehrmacht
endlich durchbrochen hat über eine
Million Menschen sind dabei ums Leben
gekommen die Blockade von Leningrad war
ein Kriegsverbrechen ein grauenhaftes
Kriegsverbrechen sie steht symbolisch
für all die Opfer die die Völker der
Sowjetunion erbracht haben im Zweiten
Weltkrieg aber alle Völker eben auch
weißrusssen Ukrainer genauso wie die
Russen meine Damen und Herren wir
verneigen uns vor diesen Opfern und wir
nehmen die Verantwortung an die uns aus
diesen Taten erwächst
aber so wenig man den Menschen in
Russland über die gräulen des Krieges
sagen musst du dringend scheint es sein
im Dialog mit der aktuellen russischen
Regierung wir müssen diesen Krieg
abwenden der uns in europa droht und
dazu und das will ich hier ausdrücklich
unterstreichen ist Diplomatie auf allen
Kanälen des Mittel der Wahl im NATO
russlandrat im normandie-format
bilateral in der OSZE und mit der
Europäischen Union das ist der Weg wie
wir versuchen Frieden zu schaffen in
Europa meine Damen und Herren
nun hat gestern Außenminister lavroff
verkündet dass für die OSZE und die
Europäische Union kein Platz am
Verhandlungstisch sei für mich heißt das
dreierlei erstens mit ihrer Ablehnung
der OSZE zeigt die Russische Föderation
das offenbar ihr Präsident nicht weniger
will als die europäische Friedensordnung
von 1990 zurückzudrehen die Ablehnung
der Karte von Paris die Ablehnung des
Wiener Dokuments vielleicht sogar die
Ablehnung der Schlussakte von Helsinki
wir müssen die russische Seite daran
erinnern dass Sie all diese Dokumente
unterschrieben hat und dass sie sich an
sie zu halten hat
zweitens
also Europäische Union bleibt der
Frieden auf dem europäischen Kontinent
unser erstes und fundamentalstes
Interesse wir sind bereit russische
Sicherheitsbedürfnisse zu adressieren
auf der Basis des Völkerrechts aber wir
sind nicht bereit meine Damen und Herren
wie ist viktoria.de gestern formulierte
wusste der russischen Regierung die
Schaffung einer zweiten Wirklichkeit
zuzugestehen nicht die NATO bedroht
Russland auch nicht die Ukraine nicht
die Nato hat die europäische
Friedensordnung durch die Verlegung von
100.000 Soldaten an die Grenzen eines
anderen Landes gestört nicht die Nato
hat Soldatinnen und Soldaten stehen in
Ländern gegen den Willen der betroffenen
Regierungen keine Nato-Soldaten stehen
in Georgien in der Republik Moldau oder
in der Ukraine es sind die Soldaten der
Russischen Föderation meine Damen und
Herren die russische Seite wäre
erheblich glaubwürdiger wenn Präsident
Putin den Rückzug dieser Truppen
anordnen würde
drittens wir dürfen uns als Westen nicht
auseinander dividieren lassen ein
Einmarsch Russlands in die Ukraine die
Vernetzung Verletzung der territorialen
Integrität und ihre Grenzen muss weitere
ernsthafte Konsequenzen für Moskau haben
politisch wirtschaftlich und finanziell
und ich finde es in diesem Hinsicht in
dieser Hinsicht extrem
gut wie eng die Abstimmung mit unseren
europäischen aber auch mit unseren
amerikanischen Partnern in der NATO
erfolgt die Nato hat gerade erklärt dass
sie bereit ist weiter mit Russland zu
reden die amerikanische Seite hat
erklärt dass sie achteinhalbtausend
Soldaten erhöhte Alarmbereitschaft
versetzt die Bedeutung von Worten und
Gesten ist allen klar aber auch das
Ziehen von roten Linien ist nötig aber
es ist dann wichtig diese roten Linien
dann auch zu respektieren und das heißt
alle Optionen liegen auf dem Tisch meine
Damen und Herren wir sollten keine von
dem Tisch nehmen um die Kalkulation
derer die in Moskau die
kriegsgefahreinheizen leichter zu machen
im Gegenteil machen wir die Kalkulation
so schwierig wie möglich machen wir den
Krieg in Europa unwahrscheinlich sichern
wir den Frieden auf unserem Kontinent
herzlichen Dank
Graf Langsdorf hat noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen woher die momentane
Aggression zumindest kommt mittlerweile
fast 120.000 Mann zusammengezogen von
den Russen an den Grenzen zu Ukraine und
sogar in Weißrussland stationiert und
Gregor Gysi der außenpolitische Sprecher
der Linksfraktion wird das jetzt
sicherlich auch noch mal aus seiner
Sicht bewerten
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
die Schwierigkeit bei dem gegenstand der
Gespräche mit Russland besteht darin
dass das so unterschiedlich gesehen wird
der Westen möchte gerne über die
Gefahren der Ukraine sprechen russland
will über eine neue sicherheitsordnung
in Europa sprechen und mit einer neuen
sicherheitsordnung wären vielleicht auch
die Gefahren für die Ukraine zu
minimieren die aber auch selbst versuche
unterlassen muss den Konflikt
ausschließlich militärisch zu sehen
welche Voraussetzung gibt es gerade
gegen den Willen Russlands müssen wir
die OSZE ein stärkere stärken ihr ein
stärkeres Gewicht wiedergeben dass sie
früher mal hatte heute kaum noch die
NATO kann ich quasi als einzige Säule
europäischer Sicherheit verstanden
werden und darf sich nicht wie bisher
gegen Russland sehen Frieden und
Sicherheit in Europa das wurde hier
schon gesagt gibt es nicht ohne
geschweige denn gegen Russland
Außenminister der frühere Außenminister
Genscher hat am zweiten februar 1990 im
Beisein vom damaligen US-Außenminister
Becker folgendes wörtlich gesagt wir
waren uns einig dass nicht die Absicht
besteht das
nato-verteidigungsgebiet auszudehnen
nach Osten das gilt nicht nur für die
DDR sondern ganz gerne Welt später hat
das auch Helmut Kohl gesagt im Gegensatz
dazu sind 14 Staaten in die NATO
aufgenommen worden
den USA ja den USA wird immer ein
Sicherheitsabstand zugebilligt wenn
jetzt wirklich schwer bewaffnete
russische Soldaten auf Kuba und in
Venezuela stationiert werden würden das
würden die USA nicht zulassen und ich
stelle an Sie die Frage warum billigen
sie der Atommacht USA ein
Sicherheitsabstand zu und der Atom macht
Russland nicht das verstehe ich nicht
ihre Kritik am Truppenaufmarsch in
Russland besteht zu Recht aber diese
Kritik ist nicht aufrichtig wenn man das
Agieren der NATO durch die Nähe ihrer
Truppen zur russischen Grenze die dort
stattfindende nato-manöver und dem
Beschluss der Ostukraine durch
Kampfdrohnen der ukrainischen Armee
auslässt übrigens Drohnen mit deutscher
Technologie aus der Türkei apropos
Türkei sie hat nicht nur Truppen und
Kriegsgerät auf eigenen Territorien an
irgendeiner Grenze stationiert sondern
es völkerrechtswidrig einmarschiert in
Syrien hat Luftangriffe geflogen alles
nur gegen kurdeln und Kurden und das
auch noch ohne die NATO zu informieren
das fragt die Bundesregierung dazu fast
nichts jeden Tag wird über Russland
gesprochen aber kaum über die Türkei
offensichtlich darf ein Nato-Partner
alles das untergräbt die Glaubwürdigkeit
der Politik
aber ich sage auch etwas die NATO sagt
das sagen sie ja auch Graf 19 sie hat
nicht die geringsten aggressiven
Absichten das mag ja sein aber wenn es
die russische Führung nicht glaubt
nutzen sie
nicht es gibt nur ein Weg das sind
Verhandlungen
Waffenlieferungen können auf gar keinen
Fall die Antwort sein in den 90er Jahren
war von einem gemeinsamen Haus Europa
die Rede das wird man nicht auf
gegenseitiger Hochrüstung bauen können
die FDP sollte vielleicht noch mal bei
Hans Dietrich Genscher
seit gestern
gibt es nun Aufforderung des Westens ich
wäre dafür dass die NATO Aufforderung an
Russland stellt zum Beispiel Ende aller
Hackingangriffe eine Reduzierung von
truppenmanövern in bestimmten Gebieten
keine Gefährdung des Souveränität der
Ukraine oder anderer Ländern wenn man
das machte sie haben ihre Forderung wir
hätten unsere Forderung dann kann man
Verhandlungen führen und solange man
Verhandlungen führt gibt es auch keinen
Krieg das ist das wichtigste
außerdem
bei den Verhandlungen muss man auch
Moskau Entgegenkommen sonst machen
Verhandlungen gar keinen Sinn man muss
ja nicht alles übernehmen aber man muss
entgegenkommen und die Bereitschaft dazu
zeigen und ich sage noch was die Ukraine
könnten wir auch dadurch sichern wenn
wir aufnahmengespräche zur EU beginnen
allerdings müssen die Werte in der
Ukraine gesichert sein es darf uns nicht
dasselbe passieren wie bei Polen und
Ungarn letzter Satz die Alternative zu
all diesen Vorschlägen wäre eine weitere
Zuspitzung mit der Gefahr eines Krieges
können wir Deutschen vor dem Hintergrund
unserer Geschichte das ernsthaft in Kauf
nehmen oder sogar daran mitwirken ich
denke auch an die heutige Gedenkstunde
die wir erlebt haben wir brauchen
Frieden durch Entspannung Deeskalation
Interessenausgleich und durch
Verhandlungen und das wird höchste Zeit
sagt Gregor Gysi der außenpolitische
Sprecher der Linken der anders als die
Russen dafür plädiert die OSZE
ordentlich zu stärken auch natürlich
gegen quasi die Möglichkeit nur mit der
NATO zu fandeln dann doch besser mit der
OSZE das ist zumindest die Meinung von
Gregor Gysi und der nächste Redner kommt
jetzt von den Grünen Robin Wagner er ist
der Sprecher für die Angelegenheiten der
Europäischen Union und ich freue mich
auch dass seine Exzellenz Herr Melnik
heute bei der Debatte hier ist
fast auf den Tag genau vor acht Jahren
am 25 januar 2014 verstarb Roman sehnig
durch die Gewalt der berkuteinheiten auf
dem euromider das heißt dass eine
Granate ihnen schwer verwundete seine
Hand zerriss und ein metallgeschoss
seine Lunge verletzte er überlebte die
Notoperation nicht
ich kenne die Biografie dieses Mannes
nicht aber er ist einer von Tausenden
die seit der Revolution der würde ihr
Leben für Demokratie für
Rechtsstaatlichkeit für Würde und
Freiheit für die Annäherung und die
Mitgliedschaft in der Europäischen Union
der Ukraine verloren haben und sie
einsetzten die Mitgliedschaft in der EU
die der Kreml seit jeher zu unterbinden
versucht es hat mich daher sehr gefreut
dass unsere neue Außenministerin diesen
Opfern am Mahnmal in Kiew auf unseren
Respekt sollte und den Menschen der
Ukraine unsere Solidarität Versicherte
sehr bekräftigt
sie hat bekräftigt dass unser Weg nach
Moskau in der Frage stets über Kiew
führen wird keine Verhandlungen über die
Ukraine ohne die Ukraine und Putin
fordert aktuell den Frieden in ganz
Europa heraus seit dem Ende des Zweiten
Weltkriegs hat es keine vergleichbaren
Truppenkonzentrationen Sand rhetorischer
Drohgebärden und Kriegspropaganda
gegeben russland hat über ein Drittel
seiner militärischen Fähigkeiten an die
ukrainische Grenze verlegt über zwei
Drittel wird aktuell von russischen
Streitkräften an der Grenze kontrolliert
wer von der NATO Einkreisung Russlands
schwadroniert hat keinen Blick für die
Realität und es ist dabei klar und dass
er märz in ihre Richtung nicht die
Ukraine sondern Russland ist es hier die
eskalieren in dieser Situation reicht
eine einzige Fehleinschätzung die einen
Flächenbrand auf dem Kontinent auslösen
könnte und in dieser Situation ist
Frieden und Diplomatie unsere Stärke die
unsere Gemeinschaft auszeichnen muss
wir brauchen daher wir brauchen daher
kein rhetorisches Wettrüsten in der Bild
auf Twitter oder hier im Saal sondern
die europa- und friedenspolitische
Klarheit unserer Außenministerin wie sie
gegenüber Außenminister laborf klauen
deutlich gemacht wurde eine überhitzte
Debatte umwaffenlieferungen schafft
keine Klarheit sie überlagert die
Diskussion zur wirkungsvollen Sanktionen
Sanktionen treffen derzeit zielgenauer
als Waffen des tun und Sanktionen
gefährden nicht das Leben der Soldaten
oder der Zivilbevölkerung in der Ukraine
oder Russland aber sie gefährden den
Machtapparat in Kreml der für die
Bedrohung unseres Friedens
verantwortlich ist den Machtapparat den
wir mit einer geschlossenen Haltung und
klaren sanktionsoperationen
entgegentreten und unmissverständlich
deutlich machen dass die europäische
Friedensordnung nicht verhandelbar ist
und weitere Verletzungen der
territorialen Integrität der Ukraine
hatte und wirtschaftliche politische und
wirtschaftliche Konsequenzen hätten und
bei denen wir im Übrigen keine
Sanktionen voreilig vom Tisch nehmen
sollten gut dass sie Herr März noch mal
die Kurve gekriegt haben bei Swift aber
es zeigt wie gefährlich voreiliges
schwadronieren in der Frage ist und ich
habe ehrlich gesagt von
viel Kritik gehört aber wenig konkrete
Vorschläge was denn wirklich passieren
soll
deutschland ist für die schwersten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen auf dem Boden
der Ukraine verantwortlich das
Verbrechen von babynahr in dem innerhalb
weniger Stunden
33.771 Menschen durch ss und Wehrmacht
ermordet wurden das eins von vielen
deutschen Verbrechen auf dem Boden der
Ukraine Russlands und Belarus die
strategische Zurückhaltung bei
Waffenlieferung sollte niemals
missverstanden werden als unterlassene
Hilfeleistung nicht in Kia von schon gar
nicht in Moskau in dieser Frage kann
sich niemand parteipolitische
Bequemlichkeiten oder simple
überschriftenpolitik leisten
es ist eine gewissen frage
ich denn wir wollen und werden das Leben
der Menschen schützen unserem
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbarte
grundsätzliche restriktive
Rüstungspolitik rührt aus der
Verantwortung unserer Geschichte und ist
zugleich Ergebnis der
gesellschaftspolitischen Entwicklung
seit 1945
mit der Ukraine und steht auch dafür
dass wir fest an der Seite der
europäischen Frieden Zuordnung stehen
vielen Dank am Schluss genau
[Applaus]
und ich erteile das Wort dem Kollegen
Roderich Kiesewetter cdu/csu-fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Holocaust Überlebende Inge
Auerbach hat uns eine Aufgabe mitgegeben
die Aufgabe lautete eine Kerze für den
Frieden zu entzünden
und wenn wir heute diese Kerze für den
Frieden entzünden würden dann würde sie
in einem erheblichen Gegenwind stehen
lassen Sie uns eine Kerze entzünden mit
der heutigen Debatte für Frieden und
gesicherte Freiheit auch für die Ukraine
nicht nur für uns liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Friedrich Merz und Alexander
Graf Lambsdorff haben sehr deutlich
gemacht dass der Verursacher der
Eskalation in Moskau sitzt und wir
müssen sehr klar ansprechen wo Ursache
und Wirkung sind und es ist
Geschichtsklitterung wenn
Gregor Gysi hier
Russland das Wort redet und Beifall von
der AFD bekommt denn erinnern wir uns an
den an die Auswirkungen was die Ukraine
durchzumachen hat im Jahr 1994
vereinbarte man im Budapester Memorandum
und in vielen Verhandlungen davor dass
die Ukraine ihren Status als
drittstärkste nuklear Macht der Welt
abgibt
die Atomwaffen übergibt um selbst
Integrität und Souveränität zu erhalten
und 2014 ist dieses Abkommen gebrochen
worden sämtliche nuklearverhandlungen
weltweit sind auf Eis weil alle das
Beispiel Ukraine fürchten das ist die
Wahrheit und Herr Klingbeil ich hätte
mir gewünscht dass sie so klare Worte
gefunden hätten wie Alexander Graf
Lamsdorf oder Friedrich Merz und Frau
Außenministerin ich hätte mir gewünscht
dass sie diesen Punkt deutlicher
herausarbeiten es ist natürlich richtig
dass wir verhandeln aber die
Bundesregierung hat in den letzten 80
Tagen kein glückliches Bild abgegeben
und unsere Hoffnung auch der Union ist
dass sie nicht in denen noch
verbleibenden Tagen bis sie die 100 Tage
voll haben die 16 Jahre verantwortlicher
Aufbau verspielen es war außenminister
Steinmeier der 2014 mit dem
minskerabkommen gemeinsam mit der
Bundeskanzlerin und dem französischen
Präsidenten erreicht hat dass wir eine
europäische Lösung finden und diese
europäische Lösung war damals gegen den
Willen der USA die auf eine militärische
Aufrüstung der Ukraine setzen aber was
ist denn aus 2014 geworden wir müssen
uns doch Gedanken machen ob unsere Art
des Umgangs seit 2014 wirklich
erfolgreich war seit wenigen Wochen seit
wenigen Wochen sind so viele Truppen um
die Ukraine stationiert wie seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht mehr
wir sind am Vorabend einer kriegerischen
Eskalation wenn wir nicht aufpassen wir
müssen auch schauen dass ein Putin sich
nicht versteigt weil eine
Erwartungshaltung im eigenen Volk
leistet wo er nicht mehr herunterkommt
und deshalb müssen wir und das erwarte
ich auch von Ihnen Herr Bundeskanzler
alles tun dass der Zusammenhalt der
Europäischen Union gewährleistet bleibt
und das
die Ukraine
[Applaus]
ernst genommen wird wir müssen zu einem
respektvolleren Umgang mit der Ukraine
kommen und nicht sorglos glauben dass
wir als die der stärkste Geber die
führende macht in der unter zivilen
Unterstützung der Ukraine dann auch auf
volles Verständnis stoßen ich möchte
nicht Klitschko zitieren weil es ein
sehr ernstes Thema ist aber wenn die
europäischen Staaten Deutschland bitten
mitzuhelfen dass Exporte bestimmter
Systeme möglich sind dann sollten wir
hinter den Kulissen ganz schnell diese
Anträge gewährleisten und wir müssen von
dem verständnisvollen Umgang mit
Russland zu einem entschiedeneren Umgang
mit Russland kommen
ich denke dass die Kanzlerin über viele
Jahre dies versucht hat aber heute
können wir nicht das Fortsetzen in dem
Sinne dass wir eine Art von
Beschwichtigung fahren wenn Russland
fast 80 Prozent seiner eigenen
Landstreitkräfte um die Ukraine
stationiert diese truppenmassierung ist
einzigartig deswegen kommt es und ich
möchte zum Schluss kommen damit die
Flamme die Kerze nicht ausgepustet wird
darauf an dass wir gemeinsam mit der EU
ein starkes Signal setzen dass wir
beiden den wir uns gewünscht haben statt
Trump dass wir beiden zeigen wir sind in
der Lage transatlantische Lastenteilung
zu bringen dass wir in der Lage sind in
der europäischen Sicherheit vorbildlich
zu wirken weil wir dann noch natürlich
im systemischen Wettbewerb mit China
zeigen ob wir überhaupt in der Lage sind
in der Gleichzeitigkeit von Krisen
weltweit Krisenprävention auch außerhalb
Europas zu leisten
und drittens liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir sollten alle Sanktionen
nicht ausschließen sie müssen halt
verhandelt werden nicht alles muss
öffentlich gemacht werden aber von
vornherein mit ausschließeritis zu
beginnen ist ein Riesenfehler und
abschließend wir müssen unsere
Bevölkerung auch darauf vorbereiten dass
Sanktionen ihren Preis haben sie werden
auch uns treffen weil sie ansonsten sind
Sanktionen wirkungslos und wenn Putin
erkennt dass wir bereit sind zu
entschiedenem Handeln ermöglichen ihm
wir ihm auch dass er die Truppen
zurückzieht ansonsten müssen wir
geschlossen bleiben und zusammenstehen
in dem Sinne danke ich Ihnen für die
Aufmerksamkeit und hoffe dass wir eine
Kerze haben die diesem Wind
entgegensteht ich danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
der nächste Redner in dieser Debatte
hier sehen wir ihn schon ist Michael
Roth für die SPD ist Vorsitzender des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses
[Applaus]
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen heute am 27
Januar erinnern wir uns der Opfer des
Holocaust
alleine 24 Millionen Menschen Soldaten
und Soldaten Zivilisten und Zivilisten
vielen dem Vernichtungskrieg von
Nazi-Deutschland auf dem Gebiet der
ehemaligen Sowjetunion zum Opfer
unendliches Leid
und wir erinnern der furchtbaren Orte
des Grauens und der Vernichtung
das betrifft aber nicht nur
das heutige Russland das betrifft eben
auch die anderen Staaten die aus der
Sowjetunion hervorgegangen sind
malitrostenes
ist ein Ort der Vernichtung und des
Grauens in Belarus
barbara ist ein Ort der Vernichtung und
des Grauens unweit von Kiew
und deshalb ist die Verantwortung über
die wir immer wieder sprechen eine
Verantwortung die wir allen Staaten des
östlichen Europas zu Teil werden dass
das erfordert viel Sensibilität aber
eben auch Mitgefühl und Empathie
die Ukraine wird nicht irgendwie
abstrakt bedroht sie wird ganz konkret
bedroht und das seit vielen vielen
Jahren
2014 die völkerrechtswidrige Annexion
der Krim
die Unterstützung die militärische
Unterstützung der Separatisten Osten der
Ukraine das ist ein kriegsähnlicher
Zustand seit vielen Jahren und jetzt der
Aufzug von 100.000
gefechtsbereiten Soldaten an der Grenze
zur Ukraine das ist eine Bedrohung der
Sicherheit nicht nur für die Ukraine
nicht nur für die Staaten und
Gesellschaften Osteuropas es ist auch
eine Bedrohung der Sicherheit für uns in
Deutschland und der Europäischen Union
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
viele in Deutschland vor allem auch
meine Partei sind stolz auf die
Ostpolitik von Willy Brandt und von
vielen anderen die im Prinzip die
Voraussetzung dafür geschaffen hat dass
Deutschland wiedervereinigt werden
konnte aber eben auch Europa wieder
vereinigt werden konnte und deshalb muss
unsere Botschaft immer sein go East
stelle fest das ist in unserer
Gesellschaft aber auch bei uns selber
viel zu wenig Interesse daran gibt was
ich derzeit im östlichen Europa abspielt
und wenn wir über eine europäische
Ostpolitik sprechen und das wäre meiner
Ermunterung und meiner Ermutigung dann
heißt das heute dass wir die
Souveränität und die Bündnisfreiheit der
Staaten im Osten Europas anerkennen über
deren Zukunft wird nicht alleine in
Moskau entschieden sondern in deren
Hauptstädten in deren Gesellschaften und
das gilt sowohl für die
NATO-Mitgliedschaft als auch für die
Mitgliedschaft in der Europäischen Union
wir dürfen keine Türen verschließen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und wenn
wir über europäische Ostpolitik sprechen
dann müssen wir immer auch die
Sicherheitsinteressen unserer
mittelosteuropäischen Partnerinnen und
Partner mit einbeziehen wir können doch
nicht einfach die Augen davor
verschließen dass ich Polen und Polen
die Menschen in den baltischen Staaten
konkret bedroht fühlen vor einer solchen
militärischen Aufrüstung und wenn wir
über
europäische Sicherheit sprechen dann
fordern wir zurecht mehr europäische
Souveränität
in der sicherheitsverteidigungs- und in
der Außenpolitik das darf aber nicht
gegen die NATO gerichtet sein sonst
verlieren wir die mittelosteuropäischen
Länder die vor allem ihre
Sicherheitsinteressen auch in der NATO
gewahrt wissen und es muss darum gehen
dass wir die Formate die wir haben auch
wieder ernst nehmen OSZE NATO
russlandrat dass wir endlich wieder auch
über Angebote sprechen können die wir
Russland unterbreiten im Bereich der
Rüstungskontrolle im Bereich der
Abrüstung dass wir wieder
vertrauensbilden tätig sind und wenn es
etwas gibt was für mich zwingend zu
einer europäischen Ostpolitik gehört
dann ist es die Zivilgesellschaft
it this society stupid wir können doch
nicht die Augen davor verschließen das
Putin seit Jahren die kritischen Teile
der Zivilgesellschaft ausgrenzt
kriminalisiert und an den Rand der
Gesellschaft drängt deswegen muss es uns
darum gehen dass wir dieser Bewegung für
Demokratie Freiheit zumindest Gehör
verschaffen Herr Putin hat doch nicht in
erster Linie Angst vor den Nato-Soldaten
und Nato-Soldaten er hat Angst vor der
Kraft von Demokratie und Freiheit die
von uns von der Europäischen Union
ausgeht und deshalb müssen wir dieser
demokratischen und freiheitlichen
Bewegung auch immer wieder zum
durchbruchverhelfen indem wir diesen
Menschen Mut machen und ihnen sagen ja
wir nehmen auch das war was mit euch
passiert
wir brauchen last but not least mehr
Austausch mehr Begegnung ich habe schon
vor Jahren vorgeschlagen dass wir ein
eigenes Jugendwerk Osteuropa auf den Weg
bringen wo sich junge Menschen aus der
Europäischen Union aus Russland aus
anderen osteuropäischen Staaten begegnen
dass wir mehr tun im Bereich von
Wirtschaft und Wissenschaft und dass wir
hier auch dazu beitragen dass wir
endlich wieder über eine
Friedensordnung sprechen können die aber
nicht darauf beruht dass Russland
permanent zur Destabilisierung
Osteuropas beiträgt das ist kein Gebot
der Stunde und darüber müssen wir reden
und deswegen sind die Gespräche die wir
jetzt zu führen auch unter maßgeblicher
Beteiligung der Bundesregierung so
unendlich wichtig
der Bundestag debattiert in einer Verein
warten Debatte über das Thema Frieden in
Europa sichern territoriale Integrität
der Ukraine waren und der nächste Redner
kommt von der AFD ist der Sprecher für
Außenpolitik hier drin
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich kann lieber Herr Roth ich kann
dieses
Gerede davon nicht mehr hören dass
Russland Europa destabilisieren will das
entbehrt jeder logischen Grundlagen
Russland
russland hat die Ressourcen wir haben
das Know-how es liegt im Interesse der
Europäischen Union alle Staaten in der
EU mit Russland zusammen zu arbeiten
genauso wie das im Interesse Russlands
liegt
und hier das was sie hier vorführen mit
ihrer Kriegstreiberei mit diesem mit mit
der Panikmache und kriegsrätorik ja das
ist richtig Russland bewegt seine Armee
auf seinem Territorium richtig darüber
wird hier sehr intensiv gesprochen wird
darüber gesprochen was in der Ukraine
passiert als als Gegenseite ich möchte
Ihnen zitieren was der ukrainische
Verteidigungsminister vorgesst
vorgestern erklärt hat
ich kann mit absoluter Gewissheit sagen
das stand heute die russischen
Streitkräfte keine
angriffsgruppierungen aufgestellt haben
die einen gewaltsamen Einmarsch in die
Ukraine durchführen könnten also bitte
betreiben sie hier nicht die
Kriegsrhetorik hier an dieser Stelle
und hier lieber Herr Roth sie haben die
Interessen Polens angesprochen wir
nehmen die Ernst ich komme gerade von
einem Gespräch mit dem estnischen
Botschafter ich war letzte Woche im
Parlament in Prag wir nehmen die
Interessen der Mittel- und
osteuropäischen Länder ernst
aber Sie müssen sehen und Herr Merz das
ist nicht richtig dass die Konfrontation
ausschließlich von Russland aus geht zu
einem Streit gehören immer zwei
mindestens zwei manchmal sogar drei
Akteure das geht nie nur mit einem
und der Akteur und das ist der Elefant
hier
im Raum der rosa Elefanten das wurde
noch überhaupt nicht angesprochen sind
die USA mehr als die USA sagen das doch
ganz offen dass sie Russland von SWIFT
abschließen wollen dass Sie ein Embargo
verhängen wollen dass Sie die
Gaslieferungen von Russland nach Europa
stoppen wollen und uns dann als Hilfe
verkauft deren überteuertes LNG
verkaufen wollen das sind doch die
Interessen die hier im Spiel sind
und ich war erstaunt liebe Frau
Außenministerin dass wir hier so schnell
Einigkeit finden wenn sie haben gesagt
man soll miteinander sprechen und die
Ukraine soll endlich an die
Vereinbarungen von Minz 2 erinnert
werden und zurück an den
verhandlungsstisch kommen dem stimmen
wir hundertprozentig zu bitte setzen Sie
sich dafür ein dass die Ukraine nicht
weiter eskaliert dass sie Fernsehsender
der Opposition nicht schließt dass sie
oppositionale Politiker wie denn unseren
Kollegen Parlaments ab kommen
widerrechtlich einsperrt sondern dass
sie zurück an den Verhandlungstisch
kommt dann werden wir wieder Frieden
haben danke schön
besitzen ungefähr 820.000 Soldaten unter
Waffen von denen jetzt etwas mehr als
100.000 direkt an der ukrainischen
Grenze aufmarschiert sind das ist Rainer
Zufall wahrscheinlich Bijan Gier Saray
hätte jetzt das Wort der außenpolitische
Sprecher der FDP
und wenn es
weiter ist der Generalsekretär der neue
und teile das Wort dem FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
seit April des letzten Jahres stehen
russische Truppen an der Grenze zu
Ukraine mit der Behauptung dass Russland
Sicherheit bedroht sei wird das Truppen
Aufgebot seitdem weiter verstärkt
Forderungen zum Abzug aus dem Gebiet und
die Warnung vor Sanktionen blieben
bisher völlig unbeachtet ich bin
weiterhin sehr besorgt über die Lage vor
Ort deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir hier
heute in deutschen Bundestag über den
Konflikt den Russland entfacht hat offen
diskutieren meine Damen und Herren nicht
die Ukraine hat diesen Konflikt entfacht
nicht die Nato hat diesen Konflikt
entfacht sondern russland hat diesen
Konflikt entfacht meine Damen und Herren
Diplomatie und Deeskalation müssen für
uns oberstes Gebot sein um bleiben
dabei dürfen wir aber die Fakten in
dieser Debatte nicht ignorieren es ist
nicht die Sicherheit Russlands die
bedroht ist es ist die Ukraine die vom
Russland bedroht wird es sind die
Menschen in der Ukraine die Angst um
ihre Zukunft haben immer öfter wird in
diesem Zusammenhang auch der Begriff der
Sicherheitsgarantie von russischer Seite
genannt ich frage mich wofür wovor
Russland eigentlich Angst hat und wofür
Russland eine Sicherheitsgarantie
braucht ich glaube nicht sagt der
Kollege Michael Roth vorhin auch zu
Recht gesagt ich glaube nicht dass
Russland Angst vor der Ukraine oder vor
der NATO hat Russland hat Angst vor
Demokratie und Freiheit es wäre ein
Albtraum
es wäre ein Albtraum für Präsident Putin
wenn die Ukraine europäisch demokratisch
und wirtschaftlich erfolgreich wäre
deswegen versucht Russland nun schon
seit vielen Jahren die Ukraine übrigens
ganz Europa zu destabilisieren
russland hat Angst vor Veränderungen und
Fortschritt wenn ehemalige
Sowjetrepubliken der Geist der Freiheit
packt ist das nur eine Frage der Zeit
bis auch im eigenen Land ähnliche
Bewegungen entstehen das lässt deutlich
erkennen dass sie außenpolitische Agenda
des Kremls stark innenpolitisch
motiviert ist es darf nicht sein dass am
Ende ein Verhandlungsergebnis steht bei
dem Russland ein Vetorecht über die
Zukunft anderer Staaten hat und Herr
Kollege Gysi Herr Kollege Gysi weil sie
das auch vorhin bei ihrer Rede erwähnt
haben es gibt ein Grund warum die
Menschen in diesen Ländern zu NATO
wollen in die NATO wollen der Grund ist
weil sie Angst vor Russland haben und
weil sie sich Hoffnung machen eine
Zukunft in Sicherheit zu haben und das
sollte bei dieser Debatte ebenfalls
erwähnt werden meine Damen und Herren
aus unserer Sicht ist das von großer
Bedeutung dass der Kreml den Preis
weiterer Eskalation kennt zu einer
realistischen Außenpolitik gehört dass
alle Optionen auf dem Tisch bleiben wenn
wir wollen dass Diplomatie eine Chance
hat und wenn wir wollen dass uns
Russland ernst nimmt dann müssen alle
Optionen auf dem Tisch bleiben meine
Damen und Herren
eine eine russische eine russische
Invasion wäre nicht irgendein fairer
Grenzkonflikt sondern ein fundamentaler
Schlag gegen unsere europäische
sicherheitsordnung und
Sicherheitsarchitektur wir sind Freunde
des russischen Volkes und haben großen
Respekt vor den Menschen in Russland wir
lehnen aber die aktuelle Politik der
russischen Führung entschieden ab der
gegenwärtige russische Weg ist ein
Irrweg der unweigerlich in die Isolation
führt Präsident Putin muss klar sein
dass sein Verhalten gravierende Folgen
haben wird die nicht im russischen
Interesse liegen können ich bedaure sehr
ich bedaure sehr meine Damen und Herren
dass derzeit eine Debatte über die
Sicherheitsarchitektur in Europa
stattfindet und diese Debatte im
Wesentlichen zwischen USA und Russland
geführt wird Europa sitzt nicht dabei
und es gibt ein Grund warum Europa nicht
dabei ist wir haben es uns ist es in den
letzten Jahren in Europa meine Damen und
Herren nicht gelungen mit einer
gemeinsamen europäischen Außen- und
Sicherheitspolitik zu sprechen wir als
Europäer haben uns in letzten Jahren
klein gemacht und jetzt bezahlen wir
auch den Preis leider dafür wir sind bei
dieser wichtigen Debatte nicht dabei ich
wünsche mir ich wünsche mir dass sich
das für die Zukunft ändert die
Prinzipien frau Präsidentin ein letzter
Gedanke die Prinzipien des Völkerrechts
des Völkerrechts der Menschenrechte und
der europäischen Friedensordnung sind
nicht verhandelbar vielen Dank meine
Damen und Herren
die John Deere Sarai hier mit der
richtigen Feststellung dass Europa
eigentlich nicht gemeinsam spricht und
nicht am Verhandlungstisch sitzt Herr
Lavra auf der Außenminister hat ja auch
gesagt die Europäer spielen für ihn
keine Rolle er sieht die Verhandlungen
mit der Amerikanern als Haupthandlung an
und dann vielleicht noch das Normandie
Format Johannes Schraps jetzt für die
SPD frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Frage die
uns hier alle beschäftigt die auch
medial derzeit drauf und runter gefragt
wird auch mir in den letzten Tagen
mehrfach sie ist an sicher etwas skurril
die Frage ob Russland nun einen Krieg
gegen die Ukraine anfängt die Frage die
Friedrich Merz hier gerade gestellt hat
ob es einen Krieg in Europa gibt sie ist
skurril denn diesen Krieg gegen die
Ukraine und da wird mir Botschafter
Melnik sicher auch zustimmen diesen
Krieg den gibt es bereits seit 2014 und
er dauert leider bis heute an sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
in diesem Sinne ist auch der erste Teil
des Titels unserer heutigen Debatte
Frieden in Europa sichern fast etwas
irreführend denn wir haben diesen Krieg
seit 2014 bereits aber in der Tat hat
sich die Situation mit dem russischen
Truppenaufmarsch in den vergangenen
Wochen besorgniserregend zugespitzt und
selbstverständlich muss aktuell deshalb
alles daran gesetzt werden um mit
diplomatischen Mitteln eine weitere
Eskalation dieses Krieges zu verhindern
so wie es unsere Bundesregierung
richtigerweise tut
offensichtlich fällt es der russischen
Staatsführung außerordentlich schwer das
Selbstbestimmungsrecht der Völker als
Grundlage des Völkerrechts anzuerkennen
und weil es Putin für seinen
innenpolitisches narrativ braucht möchte
er ebenso wenig sehen dass die
NATO-Mitgliedschaft einzelner
Nachbarstaaten keine Gefahr oder
Bedrohung für Russland dar
umso wichtiger ist es gegenüber Putin
sehr deutlich zu artikulieren das ist
erneut dass die erneut im Raum stehende
Verletzung der territorialen Integrität
der Ukraine keinesfalls toleriert wird
die Unverletzlichkeit von Grenzen
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen muss
wieder von allen akzeptiert werden
insofern stimmt zumindest der zweite
Teil des Titels unserer Debatte und ich
bin froh dass dieses klare Signal auch
aus dieser heutigen Debatte ganz
eindeutig hervorgeht
in den letzten Tagen wurde immer wieder
Kritik daran laut dass Deutschland keine
Waffen an die Ukraine liefert für mich
persönlich bleibt die Frage offen ob
Waffenlieferungen in die Ukraine
tatsächlich mehr Sicherheit gegenüber
einer Bedrohung durch Russland bringen
oder ob sie nicht im Gegenteil einen
Konflikt anheizen können der vielleicht
besser auf anderen Wegen entschärft
werden sollte unsere Position ist
jedenfalls deutlich solange eine
friedliche Lösung möglich ist werden wir
sie anstreben und dafür muss auf
diplomatischem Wege jede Möglichkeit
genutzt werden verehrte Kollegen
und das ist halt dann auch nichts mit
russlandfreundlichkeit oder mit
Freundlichkeit zu irgendeinem Land zu
tun sondern mit einem umsichtigen
bedachten vorgehen dass auf eine
friedliche Konfliktlösung ausgerichtet
ist und zugleich sagen wir der
russischen Führung ja ganz klar und
deutlich dass ein Einmarsch in die
Ukraine ein sehr hohen Preis haben würde
und zu Recht tun wir das in der heutigen
Debatte ja parteiübergreifend auch noch
mal mit besonderem Nachdruck verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen als
Europapolitiker möchte ich hier noch
einen Aspekt betonen der mir in einer
zumindest öffentlich medial teilt sehr
polarisierten Debatte viel zu kurz
kommen nämlich die gemeinsame
europäische Außenpolitik
der EU-Außenbeauftragte Josef Borrell er
hatte die hat die Ukraine zurecht als
einen Teil Europas bezeichnen und auch
betont das ist keine Sicherheit in
Europa ohne die Sicherheit der Ukraine
gibt beides stimmt nur sitzt Europa das
hat der Kollege Jägerei gerade
richtigerweise angesprochen bei den
Gesprächen zwischen Putin den USA der
NATO selten wirklich mit am Tisch und
wir müssen als Europäer aufpassen dass
wir in einer Großmacht
Auseinandersetzung auf europäischer
stellvertreterbühne nicht zum vollkommen
unbeteiligten Zuschauer werden
leider wird in der öffentlichen Debatte
aber weniger über die Möglichkeiten
eines gemeinsamen europäischen Vorgehens
gesprochen wie es Außenministerin
baerbock dankenswerterweise vorhin sehr
deutlich getan hat vielmehr werden
vermeintliche Unterstützungsleistungen
einzelner Länder einander
gegenübergestellt und gegeneinander
aufgewogen die baltischen Staaten
liefern Luftabwehrraketen die Ukraine
versucht gegenüber Deutschland aus der
Fehlleistung einer einzelnen Person die
nebenbei bemerkt sehr klare und schnelle
Konsequenzen nach sich gezogen hat sehr
grundsätzliche Forderungen abzuleiten
Polen verkauft bereits seit Jahren
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge an die Ukraine die
Briten liefern Panzerabwehrwaffen und
Deutschland und Frankreich versuchen
derweil im normandieformat auf
diplomatischen Wege zu einer Entspannung
des Konflikts beizutragen es ist gut
dass seit gestern in Paris nach langer
Zeit endlich wieder Gespräche in diesem
Format stattfanden und ich denke wir
alle wünschen uns dass Sie erfolgreich
zu einer dskalation beitragen können die
Beispiele zeigen aber deutlich nicht den
fehlenden Konsens für eine gemeinsame
EU-Außenpolitik und diese Uneinigkeit
die bringt Europa in die Zuschauerrolle
dabei geht es nicht nur um die aktuelle
Situation sondern es geht um die
grundsätzliche Frage ob Europa als
starker politischer Akteur gemeinsam
handeln und auftreten kann kurzfristig
wünsche ich mir deshalb eine
diplomatische Konfliktlösung über die
gestern wieder begonnenen Gespräche im
normandieformat mittel und langfristig
wünsche ich mir dass wir Europäer
endlich als gemeinsamer außenpolitischer
Akteur auftreten um uns in
Konfliktsituationen nicht als kleine
Einzelstaaten sondern gemeinsam mit
Kraft und Nachdruck für friedliche
Lösungen einsetzen können herzlichen
Dank für die aufmerksam
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Schatz
gemeinsame Außenpolitik früher hat die
stattgefunden in Europa das
minzgrabkommen kam ja nur zustande weil
Herr weil die Franzosen und die
deutschen gemeinsam gearbeitet haben und
ob das immer noch so sein kann das ist
die Frage ob per Putin das auch so sieht
die nächste Florian Harn jetzt der
verteilungspolitische Sprecher der
cducsu wenn ich die sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn ich die
ersten Wochen der Regierungsarbeit der
neuen links gelben Koalition betrachte
muss ich immer wieder an einen Satz aus
einer legendären Reportage von den
Olympischen Winterspielen 1980 in Placid
denken der damalige zDF-Reporter Bruno
Morawetz rief damals mit Blick auf den
Verlauf der
langlaufdisziplin wo ist bele haben wir
noch nicht gesehen wir wissen nichts wir
sehen ihn nicht bele ist weg
wie würde Morawetz wo die aktuelle
Arbeit der Bundesregierung und ihre
Performance zu den aktuellen Topthemen
wie Impfpflicht oder Ukraine
kommentieren er würde vermutlich rufen
wo ist Scholz Scholz haben wir noch
nicht gesehen wir wissen nichts wir
sehen und hören ihn nicht Scholz ist weg
denn das ist denn das ist denn das ist
der Eindruck
denn das ist der Eindruck den nicht nur
wir sondern zunehmend auch ein Großteil
der Bevölkerung im Moment von ihnen und
ihrer Arbeit haben Herr Bundeskanzler
gravieren kommt hinzu dass das auch der
Eindruck der Bündnispartner in Europa
und in der NATO ist sie waren 16 Jahre
andere Regierungen des Arbeit gewohnt
nämlich das konsequente Engagement einer
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel sie hat
die europäische Familie zusammengehalten
und den Draht nach Moskau nie abreißen
lassen sie hat mit Putin auf Augenhöhe
in Minsk verhandelt und in ihrer
Amtszeit wussten unsere Partner auf
Deutschland kann man sich verlassen
wo ist Albrecht ich finde die
bundesverteidigungsministerin die als
Inhaberin der befehls- und Kommando
Gewalt der Bundeswehr eine der größten
Streitkräfte in Europa und in der NATO
in sie sollte in dieser Frage doch auch
eine besonders aktive Rolle spielen sie
ist heute noch nicht mal hier bei dieser
Rede auf der Regierungsbank dass sie
aber bis zum gestrigen Tag noch nicht
einmal ein Gespräch mit dem ukrainischen
Amtskollegen geführt hat spricht auch
Bände wir als cdu/csu wollen dass die
ukraine-krise diplomatisch gelöst wird
das bedeutet verhandeln auf höchstem
Niveau dabei ist es entscheidend
mögliche Maßnahmen und folgen einer
russischen Eskalation nicht unnötig vom
Tisch zu nehmen das gilt auch für die
Frage von Waffenlieferungen zur Stärkung
der Selbstverteidigung der Ukraine eine
schwierige Frage gerade für Deutschland
wir stehen im traditionell sehr
skeptisch gegenüber dass dies aber auch
richtig und wichtig sein kann hat sich
bei der Unterstützung für die Kurden zur
bekämpf dass sie es gezeigt deshalb
sollten wir diese Option eben nicht vom
Tisch nehmen und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn wir über die ukraine-krise
sprechen und Weltpolitik machen dann
entsteht manchmal der Eindruck dass wir
die Menschen vergessen die diese Krise
direkt betrifft und das sind die
Menschen in der Ukraine das sind zum
Beispiel Mütter und Väter die Angst um
ihre Kinder haben die im Zweifel bereit
sind ihr Land und die Freiheit der
Ukraine zu verteidigen diese Menschen
erhoffen sich von uns Unterstützungen
dieser Krise deshalb ist es so wichtig
ein Signal zu setzen Europa und der
Westen sind an der Seite der Ukraine
besonders hoch ist dabei gerade auch der
Erwartungsdruck auf Deutschland dass die
Bundesregierung glaubt mit einer
Lieferung von 5000 Helmen an die Ukraine
dieses Signal der Unterstützung zu
senden und dem Erwartungsdruck an uns
her zu werden ist ein großer Irrtum das
war
das war kein Befreiungsschlag Liebe
Bundesregierung sondern ein echter
beschämender rohrkrippierer und meine
Damen und Herren wir fragen uns in
diesen Tagen und auch bei dieser Debatte
immer wieder warum kommt es zu dieser
Krise und was ist der Grund für den
Konflikt den die Ukraine und am besten
auf der einen Seite und die Russische
Föderation auf der anderen Seite
miteinander haben ich glaube ein Grund
ist dass wir diametral andere Ansichten
darüber haben was im Interesse eines
Landes auch mit Blick auf die
Nachbarschaftspolitik ist wir haben
durch die europäische Integration
gelernt geht es unserem Nachbarn gut
profitieren wir selbst massiv davon
moskau sieht das genau anders dort
befürchtet man den Erfolg des Nachbarns
weil er Gefahr für die eigene innere
Stabilität ist nichts wird dort so
gefürchtet wie die Freiheit die
Meinungsfreiheit die Wahlfreiheit die
Religionsfreiheit die Pressefreiheit und
die Versammlungsfreiheit und diese
Freiheit beansprucht die Ukraine zu
Recht für sich und wir können gar nicht
anders als sie dabei auch zu
unterstützen
klar ist aber auch das Russland unser
Nachbar ist und bleibt und wir natürlich
ein übergroßes Interesse an einer guten
und gedeihlichen Zusammenarbeit haben
deshalb bitte ich uns alle lassen sie
uns alle alles daran setzen diesen
Konflikt im Interesse aller zu
entschärfen die cdu/csu-fraktion in
ihrer Rolle wird sich dabei in diesem
Sinne zu tausend Prozent engagieren
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
mittlerweile hat Wolfgang Kubicki das
Pult übernommen als amtierender
Sitzungspräsident und der letzte Redner
hier in der Debatte wird jetzt so
Weingarten von der SPD sein er ist
Mitglied im Verteidigungsausschuss
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren die aktuelle Lage in und um die
Ukraine ist brandgefährlich sie bedroht
den Frieden in ganz Europa und die
Ukraine in ihrer territorialen
Integrität es ist doch unstrittig und je
mehrfach schon deutlich geworden die
Regierung im Kreml ist der Aggressor
nicht die Ukraine Russland versucht sein
Interessen mit militärischen
Drohgebärden durchzusetzen das werden
wir nicht akzeptieren deswegen unser
klarer Appell Präsident Putin ziehen sie
ihre Truppen von der ukrainischen Grenze
zurück und unterlassen Sie alle
Maßnahmen zur Destabilisierung der
Ukraine
mich irritieren jedoch auch manche
Reaktionen in unserer deutschen
Diskussion ich höre dort teilweise eine
Lust an der konfliktverschärfung heraus
die der Brisanz der Lage nicht
angemessen ist
weder die Leier von einer stets
aggressiven nato-politik noch die
kritiklose Verehrung der russischen
Gewaltpolitik die wir hier aus den
linken und rechten Fraktionen des
Deutschen Bundestages hören werden der
Problem gerecht wir brauchen keine
Ideologie sondern pragmatisches Handeln
und es ist eine völlig falsche
Sichtweise zu hoffen dass die Lieferung
von totbriefen bringenden Waffen in
dieser Krisensituation etwas zu
Entspannung der Krise beitragen würde
die sozialdemokratische
Bundestagsfraktion stützt deshalb ohne
Einschränkung die Linie der
Bundesregierung und des Bundeskanzlers
keine letalen Waffen in das Krisengebiet
zu liefern
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
die zwar nicht in der Lage sich sind
sich den Namen der
bundesverteidigungsministerin zu merken
die heißt nämlich lambrechter Kollege
Hahn aber gleichzeitig weitere
Waffenlieferungen fordern machen Sie
sich doch nichts vor deutsche
Waffenlieferungen in die Ukraine würden
wenig helfen aber gleichzeitig von der
Kreml Propagandamaschine als massive
Provokation verstanden werden egal wie
gut unsere Vorsätze unsere Begründungen
dabei wären und weitere Provokationen
brauchen wir nicht Deutschlands Rolle
muss eine andere sein Druck auf Russland
auszuüben ohne die militärische
Situation anzuheizen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
stehen auch zu unseren Verbündeten in
der NATO unsere Truppen in Litauen
stehen dort nicht nur symbolisch unser
herzlicher Dank gilt unseren Soldatinnen
Soldaten und ihrem Einsatz jegliche
Angriff auf diese Verbündeten und auch
auf unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten wäre
auf ein Angriff auf die NATO insgesamt
wir nehmen auch die Bedrohungen die
unsere polnischen und baltischen Partner
inzwischen auch und die finnischen und
schwedischen Freunde spüren sehr ernst
über ihre Sicherheitsinteressen werden
wir nicht hinweggehen Bündnisfreiheit
und Völkerrecht sind nicht verhandelbar
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
sehr viel die Rede von Respekt dass es
auch richtig die Völker Russlands und
der Ukraine verdienen Respekt mehr noch
angesichts dessen was Sie was Ihnen aus
unserem Land heraus angetan wurde
verdienen Sie unsere Demut Demut vor
ihrer Geschichte und ihren Opfern aber
das gilt auch für beide Seiten dieses
Konflikts auch Politiker verdienen
Respekt jedenfalls manche sei Präsident
Putin an dieser Stelle vor mehr als 20
Jahren im September 2001 gesprochen hat
hat er viel getan um den ihm gebührenden
Respekt zu schmälern die Unterdrückung
der demokratischen Opposition und der
Zivilgesellschaft Einschränkung der
Pressefreiheit das aggressive Verhalten
gegenüber den Nachbarn
unser Wille zum Gespräch bleibt aber
weitgehend und weiterhin unverändert wir
Sozialdemokraten unterstützen das
normandiefon da Format mit Russland der
Ukraine Frankreich und Deutschland wir
begrüßen ausdrücklich das Präsident
macron und Bundeskanzler Scholz hier
engagiert vorangehen Dialog statt
Eskalation der Kreml muss die eskalieren
aber alle Beteiligten können zur
Stabilisierung der äußerst gefährlichen
Lage beitragen lassen Sie uns gemeinsam
auf diesem Weg weitergehen herzlichen
Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr Weingarten
damit schließe ich
die Debatte
der tagesauspunkt damit erledigt ich
rufe auf den tagesauspunkt 5 vereinbarte
Debatte zur Konferenz zur Zukunft
Europas für die Aussprache Dauer von ja
was ist die Konferenz der Zukunft
Europas Beteiligung statt Bürokratie mit
großangelegten bürgerdebatten will die
EU nahbare und transparenter werden die
Konferenz zur Zukunft Europas wurde am 9
mai 2021 im Europaparlament gestartet
sie besteht aus einer Vielzahl von
Veranstaltungen und einer zentralen
Online-Plattform auf beiden Wegen können
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ihre Ideen für
die Zukunft der EU äußern ein Ausschuss
aus Vertretern und Vertreterinnen von
Parlament EU-Kommission und Rat der EU
soll dies bündeln und den drei Organen
vorstellen und die erste Rednerin zu
diesem Punkt ist die Staatsministerin im
Auswärtigen Amt Anna Lührmann die für
den Bereich Europa und Klammer im
Energie zuständig ist
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
für die Demokratie ist diese Pandemie
eine enorme Herausforderung das merken
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger das merken
wir Abgeordnete im parlamentsalltag
umso bemerkenswerter ist es dass Europa
mitten in der Pandemie das größte
Experiment aller Zeiten zur besseren
Beteiligung der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
gestartet hat die Zukunftskonferenz
damit beweist die EU dass die
europäische Demokratie sehr wohl
funktioniert und sehr wohl lebendig ist
dass sie mit immer neuen Ideen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger besser beteiligen
will liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Zukunftskonferenz ist ein Booster für
die europäische Demokratie
und das liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ist auch wirklich ein Grund stolz zu
sein auf Europa und Vertrauen in die
Demokratie zu haben
die EU hat erstmals alle Europäerinnen
und Europäer um konkrete Ideen zur
Zukunft Europas gebeten über eine
Webseite in den europäischen und in den
nationalen bürgerdialogen in der
Zukunftskonferenz im Auswärtigen Amt
haben wir kürzlich einen nationales
Bürgerforum mit über 100 gelosten
Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmern
organisiert ganz besonders beeindruckt
hat mich der Enthusiasmus der
Teilnehmenden die Ideen sprudelten nur
so und am letzten Wochenende haben wir
in Straßburg einige von ihnen waren
dabei begonnen uns in der
Zukunftskonferenz mit den Vorschlägen
auseinanderzusetzen
das war insgesamt eine sehr sehr
konstruktive Debatte mit Politikerinnen
und Politikern aus dem Europäischen
Parlament aus den nationalen Parlamenten
und Regierungen aber
zwei Arten von Wortmeldungen die mich
sehr nachdenklich gemacht haben
manche Rednerinnen und Redner waren
extrem ablehnend gegenüber den
Vorschlägen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
das geht so nicht das haben wir doch
noch nie so gemacht die EU sei gut so
wie sie ist
andere haben versucht die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger zu vereinnahmen
entweder für ihre eigenen Zwecke oder
indem Sie einfach das Blaue vom Himmel
vorunter versprochen haben
wir setzen das jetzt alles sofort um
wurde da gesagt
beides ist nicht die Antwort der
Bundesregierung
sondern wir werden uns ernsthaft mit den
Vorschlägen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
auseinandersetzen
da gibt es nämlich Ideen da frage ich
mich warum machen wir das nicht schon
längst so
mit einem Onboarding Paket soll jedem
und jeder Informationen über europäische
Werte zur Verfügung gestellt werden
viele andere konkrete Ideen für mehr
Beteiligung und für eine europäische
Öffentlichkeit eine eu-tv wurden auch
vorgelegt
dann gibt es großartige Ideen die Kosten
aber sehr viel Geld ich war ja mit
meinem Mitglied im Haushaltsausschuss
da würden werden sicherlich sehr genau
darüber reden müssen und gemeinsam dafür
kämpfen um sowas in den Haushalten
unterzubringen zum Beispiel EU-Förderung
für Schüleraustausch
und es gibt Vorschläge die so ähnlich
sind wie Vorhaben die wir gerade schon
in Brüssel oder auch hier im Bundestag
sehr intensiv diskutieren
dazu gehört zum Beispiel die grenzabgabe
beim Import klimaschädlicher Produkte
eine garantierte Lebensdauer ein
Lebenszyklus von Produkten Mindestlohn
hier müssen die Vorschläge der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wirklich konkret
in den Prozess einfließen
und zwar eine ernsthaften Debatte gehört
es aber auch klar zu sagen es gibt auch
Vorschläge die vermutlich schwer
umzusetzen sein werden aus technischen
Gründen zum Beispiel weil es nicht
funktionieren kann so ist das eben bei
einem Brainstorming Prozess da kommen
viele Ideen raus und einige davon muss
man dann wieder verwerfen bei anderen
Vorschlägen kommt die EU an die Grenzen
ihrer Handlungsfähigkeit zum Beispiel
für ihre Werte nach innen aber auch nach
außen entschieden eintreten deshalb
lautet ein Vorschlag auch die Regeln der
Einstimmigkeit zu überprüfen solche
Debatten müssen wir jetzt gemeinsam
ambitioniert und entschlossen angehen
denn ein starkes Europa ist ein Europa
dass die Empfehlung seiner Bürgerinnen
und Bürger wirklich ernst nimmt dass die
Anregung nicht in einer Schublade
verschwinden lässt sondern Wege findet
wie die besten davon auch Realität
werden können und dabei setzt sich auf
Ihre Unterstützung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin ja und zentrales Gremium ist
das sogenannte Plenum dem 433 Menschen
angehören sollen neben Politikern aus
den EU-Staaten den nationalen
Parlamenten und dem Europaparlament auch
zufällig ausgewählte normale Menschen
nicht normales Gunter Kriechbaum denn er
ist Sprecher für Europapolitik der Union
und er war dabei genauso wie zum
Beispiel Axel Schäfer sein Kollege von
der SPD als es vor einer Woche zur
dritten Sitzung ging herr Präsident
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen die
Zukunftskonferenz ist schon jetzt ein
Erfolg denn es gibt ein positiven Schub
bei den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern in
Europa man debattiert mit diskutiert
über Europa quer durch die Republik quer
durch Europa hindurch auch in meiner
Heimatstadt in Pforzheim eine Stadt mit
sehr hohem Migrationshintergrund
debattiert man und streitet man
leidenschaftlich über und für die
europäischen Themen das Thema Europa
findet Eingang in die Schulen aber bei
Lichte bestehen müssen wir auch sagen es
ist noch mächtig Luft nach oben hier
würde ich mir zum Beispiel auch gerade
von den Ländern wünschen dass dieses
Thema noch stärker über die
Kultusministerkonferenz in die Schulen
eingespeist wird und wir gerade auch bei
den jungen Generation hier für einen
positiven Aufschlag sorgen wir müssen
uns mit diesen Vorschlägen die die
Bürger machen auseinandersetzen und Frau
Staatsministerin Lohmann hat es auch
gerade schon angesprochen einer der
Wünsche aus der Bürgerschaft heraus ist
beispielsweise der Wunsch nach mehr
strategischer Autonomie in Europa in der
Welt
wenn wir das sehen dann müssen wir uns
in der Tat kritisch die Frage stellen ob
wir noch
weltpolitikfähig sind das bedeutet mit
Blick beispielsweise auf China
das Chinas sehr wohl eine Strategie hat
für Europa auch für Afrika aber wir
umgekehrt keine für China
auch hier lohnt sich ein Blick auf die
unterschiedlichen Verhältnisse wird
debattieren wir debattieren hier
leidenschaftlich in Deutschland in
Europa ob wir Huawei auf den
europäischen Markt lassen sollen ja oder
nein bei Lichte besehen ist das aber gar
keine Frage über Huawei sondern das
Problem liegt darin dass wir keine
europäische Antwort haben dass wir kein
European oder besser gesagt Global
Player haben der hier Huawei das Wasser
reichen könnte über dies
wir die debattieren dann darüber ob wir
es zulassen dürfen dass wir gemeinsame
Züge bauen dürfen mit allstrom und
Siemens aber wir versperren uns über das
Wettbewerbsrecht der Europäischen Union
wertvolle Wege die wir brauchen um hier
in der Globalisierung bestehen zu können
auch das ist wichtig wenn wir eine
strategische Autonomie anstreben wollen
eine andere Entwicklung die wir in
Deutschland eigentlich kaum wahrnehmen
jedenfalls eine Diskussion die wir nicht
führen eine Konzentration auf dem
Finanzdienstleistungsmarkt schauen wir
auf die zehn größten Banken gemessen am
Börsenwert dann findet sich darunter
keine einzige europäische Bank 5 kommen
aus China 5g aus den USA doch brutaler
und dramatischer fällt der Blick auf
wenn wir auf die
Bilanzsumme schauen die vier größten
Banken kommen alle aus China was
bedeutet das jetzt für uns in Europa
jeder jeder Bürger jede Bürgerin und
jeder Bürger der und die schon mal eine
Finanzierung hat machen müssen weiß dass
man vor das Geld fließt die Daten
fließen müssen das heißt jedes
Unternehmen wenn sie China im
europäischen Markt investiert muss Daten
liefern und ermöglicht damit den
Einblick in die Herz nur eines
Unternehmens das heißt auch an dieser
Stelle müssen wir aufpassen dass wir uns
strategisch klug genug aufstellen denn
es geht nicht nur um die Unternehmen
sondern auch um die Volkswirtschaften
und der Einfluss China in der Welt und
vor allem in Europa steigt beharrlich
wenn wir über die weltpolitikfähigkeit
Reden und den Wunsch nach mehr
strategische Autonomie dann geht es
natürlich auch um die Ukraine
die Ukraine war nun gerade
debattengegenstand deswegen möchte ich
mir da weitere Ausführungen auch sparen
aber es fällt natürlich schon auf dass
aktuell die Gespräche in genflaufen über
zentrale europäische Sicherheitsfragen
aber Europa hier nicht mit am Tisch
verhandelt und nicht mit am Tisch sitzt
unsere Entscheidung ist derweil klar die
Ukraine ist ein souveränes Land und
es ist zunächst einmal der Entscheidung
dieser Länder ob sie sich den Standards
der Europäischen Union annähern wollen
oder nicht aber wenn das wie im Falle
der Ukraine dann auch erfolgt ist dann
kann es nicht sein dass Russland hier
ein Mitspracherecht für sich reklamiert
das sollte auch Herrn Gysi eigentlich
klar sein denn würde man das zu billigen
wollen dann wäre das ein Revival dann
wäre das eine Wiederbelebung der brechen
ihres Doktrin aber brechen jetzt ist
genauso tot wie die brechen
sein sollten
wenn wir
überhaupt auf Russland schauen dann
werden wir an einem Punkt immer
auseinander liegen das was wir als
unsere Werte Betrachten der Freiheit der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit der Demokratie sind
aus Sicht von Herrn Putin reale
Bedrohungslage er kann mit Freiheit
genauso wenig anfangen wie mit
Demokratie eine der Forderungen und Frau
Hörmann sie wissen es was ja mit dabei
waren ist auch die Frage nach einer
europäischen Armee dabei wird ein Stück
weit übersehen dass wir ja schon im
Prozess der verstärkten Zusammenarbeit
Tesco auf den Weg gebracht haben das
heißt willige Länder die hier vorangehen
wollen können es dann auch tun und
machen es dann auch aber bis zu einer
europäischen Armee ist es noch ein sehr
sehr weiter Schritt
und ein sehr weiter Weg denn das würde
zunächst einmal bedeuten dass wir schon
mal beim Beschaffungswesen einheitliche
Standards bekommen aber auch hier gibt
es keine europaweiten Ausschreibungen
weil mit Blick auf Frankreich sich auch
einzelne nationale Mitgliedsländer
dagegen wären aber auch an die eigene
Adresse gesprochen wenn wir tatsächlich
den Verteidigungsbereich europäisieren
möchten dann heißt das auch im Klartext
dass wir von den weltweit strengsten
rüstungsexportgesetzen die wir nun mal
haben auch Abstriche machen müssen sonst
kommen wir hier zu keiner echten
Europäisierung
ich möchte schließen damit dass die
Zukunftskonferenz sehr sehr viele gute
Ideen liefert auch Positionen vermittelt
die uns zu einer Rückbesinnung
verpflichtet denn wir müssen jetzt auch
schauen dass wir dieser
Zukunftskonferenz eine Zukunft geben
ich möchte da ausdrücklich die Partner
die Projektpartner ermutigen
weiterzumachen Frau Hartung
beispielsweise von Pauls of Europe
steckt hier enorm viel Engagement hinein
und wenn wir als Parlamentarier
Europäisches Parlament nationale
Parlamente diese Idee nicht aufgreifen
und diskutieren dann würde sehr viel
Enttäuschung zurückbleiben und das wäre
es das wäre fatal das können wir nicht
wollen und ich freue mich deswegen jetzt
auf eine Fortsetzung auch dieses
Prozesses im Mai noch während der
Ratspräsidentschaft der französischen
Ratspräsidentschaft wird dann wohl der
abschlussbereich vorgelegt werden aber
wie gesagt weitermachen ist deswegen
sinnvoll weil wir dann viele weitere
Menschen für das europäische Projekt
auch begeistern können vielen Dank
vergangene Woche Freitag und Samstag
fand die dritte Nase zum in Straßburg
Stadt Günter Kriechbaum war da aber auch
der nächste Redner Axel Schäfer sie
nahmen als Vertreter der Konferenz für
den Deutschen Bundestag Teilen genau 50
Sekunden
natürlich etwas mache ich trotzdem
die Zeit der Wahl ist gleich vorbei ist
noch ein Mitglied des Hauses anwesend
dass seine Stimme nicht abgegeben hat
ich erkenne dass es nicht der Fall ist
rennt auch niemand mehr auf der
West-
also alle Kollegen haben ihre Stimme
abgegeben dann schließe ich die Wahlen
bitte die Schriftführer und
Schriftführer mit der Ausbildung zu
beginnen die Ergebnisse der Wahlen
werden ihn später bekannt gegeben
Richter Wahlausschuss die Abgeordneten
hatten jetzt 100 Minuten Zeit hier ihre
Stimmkarten abzugeben jetzt also ist es
beendet und ich hatte ihn angesprochen
Axel Schäfer auch er war bei dieser
dritten Plenarsitzung vergangene Woche
dabei für die SPD
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir haben eine vereinbarte
Debatte über die Zukunft Europas es hat
länger gedauert zu dieser Vereinbarung
zu kommen als zum Beispiel meiner
Fraktion sich das gewünscht hätte und es
hat auch was mit dem Zustand Europas zu
tun vieles dauert leider länger als die
überzeugten föderalistin und
Föderalisten sich das wünschen aber wir
sind jetzt tatsächlich an einem Punkt
angekommen wo wir sagen müssen dürfen
auch können ja wir befinden uns auf der
Höhe der Zeit wir befinden uns auf der
Höhe der Zeit
wohl eine große Mehrheit der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger für mehr europäische
Zusammenarbeit für mehr europäischen
Zusammenhalt aber auch für mehr
europäischen Zusammenschluss sich
ausspricht und gleichzeitig eine leider
wachsende Minderheit für Nationalismus
für Abgrenzung und Ausgrenzung sich
lauthals artikuliert und gerade wir
wissen
nationalismus ist ein Irrtum der auf
einen Irrweg führt und in einem Irrsinn
nämlich Krieg endet und deshalb ist
dieses europäische diese europäische
Aufgabe eben die Aufgabe des Friedens
und gegen jegliche Form des
Nationalismus
und wer sind deshalb auf der Höhe der
Zeit weil zum ersten Mal in Europa über
den Fortschritt eben nicht nur wie am
Beginn des Einigungsprozesses vor 70
Jahren die Regierung standen später ein
Parlament was zwar viel zu sagen aber
nicht zu entscheiden hatte sondern jetzt
das Europäische Parlament
gleichberechtigt mit der nationalen
Parlamenten und einer gleichen Zahl von
engagierten Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
diskutieren und Vorschläge machen und
das sollten wir aufnehmen das sollten
wir ernst nehmen und das sollten wir
voranbringen gerade hier liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Deutschen
Bundestag
und diese besondere Verpflichtung zeigt
sich auch und ich finde das sollten wir
gemeinsam in den demokratischen Parteien
stolz sein dass der Austausch zwischen
den Parlamenten bei uns bisher schon
ziemlich gut funktioniert hat wir haben
hier von Friedrich Merz über Alexander
Graf Langsdorf Claudia Roth auch bis hin
zu Sahra Wagenknecht und ich gehöre auch
zu dieser Riege Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die schon im Europäischen Parlament
waren und jetzt im Bundestag sind und wo
es deutlich darauf ankommt dass wir die
Rechte des Europäischen Parlaments
stärken ihre demokratischen
Möglichkeiten ausbauen dass eine
zentrale Forderung der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger mit denen wir bisher auf der
Zukunftskonferenz diskutiert haben
und dazu gehört natürlich immer auch
dass wir mit dem anfangen was schon
heute möglich ist und aus übrigens gar
kein Geld kostet ich appelliere noch mal
daran dass wir im Deutschen Bundestag
ebenso wie im Europäischen Parlament
eine öffentliche Debatte auch in den
Ausschüssen führen auch das ist für die
Beteiligung von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
so wichtig und dass wir auch die
Konsequenzen bei der nächsten Europawahl
mit transson und Sandalen Listen und
vielen anderen Möglichkeiten auch hier
in deutschen Bundestag diskutieren und
entscheiden und nicht sagen wir warten
bis alle anderen auch dafür sind sondern
ein Stückchen wieder eine Vorreiterrolle
einnehmen wie es unsere Vorväter und der
Mütter hier getan haben die als erste
gefordert haben die Direktwahl eines
Europäischen Parlaments weit bevor das
1978/79 beschlossen
und liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen ich will
an dieser Stelle es ist von Vorredner
Grund der Christbaum dank in zweiter
Weise auch schon getan worden noch mal
an die Länder auch appellieren sie sind
da sehr stark repräsentiert mit
Ministerinnen
Staatssekretärinnen und auch
Parlamentspräsidentin erfreulich viele
Frauen das auch das bitteschön die
Aufgabe von Parlamenten in den Ländern
ist dass das diskutiert wird genauso wie
das zu den demokratischen europäischen
Fraktion dort gehört
und ich appelliere auch und wir sind ja
alle in Wahlkreisen beheimatet wir
wohnen ja in Städten und Gemeinden
deshalb
appelliere ich an die kommunale Ebene
das zu tun was die Spitzenverbände auch
formuliert gefordert erwartet haben
nämlich dieses Thema Zukunft Europas
weil die Menschen eben vor Ort leben und
nicht irgendwo in Ländern auch zu einer
Sache der Debatten der Ratssitzung der
Gemeindevertretung vor Ort zu machen das
findet sein wir doch ganz ehrlich das
findet zurzeit viel zu wenig statt und
deshalb sollten wir das auch ermutigen
ich werde meinen persönlichen Beitrag
leisten und meine Ehefrau
Bürgermeisterin in diesem Sinne auch ein
Stückchen zusätzlich ermutigen ich gehe
davon aus dass sie das auch sowieso
macht
nein Günther das ist nur die gleiche
parteifamilie und die gleiche
europäische Überzeugung die ich mit
meiner lieben Frau seit 50 Jahren Teile
ja liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
entscheidend ist ja immer der Prozess
das heißt die Diskussion dass wir sie
führen und wie wir sie führen aber der
Prozess muss auch zu Ergebnissen niemals
zu abschließenden aber doch zu
zukunftsführenden Ergebnissen führen und
deshalb ist es doch so wichtig dass das
was hier gelungen ist mit der neuen
Koalition und in einem Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart und der besondere
Verantwortung der drei Parteien dass das
auch umgesetzt werden dass wir das hier
auch wiederholen jawohl diese
Bundesregierung diese Mehrheit des
Bundestages hat festgehalten die
Ergebnisse der Konferenz zur Zukunft
Europas werden wir nehmen aufnehmen
ernst nehmen und mit diesen Ergebnissen
zum Beispiel fordern dass es ein Konvent
gibt der auch
vertragsveränderungen in den
europäischen Verträgen ermöglicht um
tatsächlich auf dem Weg eine
fortschreitenden Integration
voranzukommen das ist ein Versprechen
und das werden wir hier gemeinsam halten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Idee
zur Zukunftskonferenz Europas kam vom
französischen Präsidenten
Emmanuel macron ich bedauere sehr dass
wir damals in Deutschland nicht mutiger
mit einer Antwort und einer Zustimmung
gewesen sind lass uns das heute ein
Stückchen nachholen und lass uns das
gleichzeitig in Europa mit unseren
französischen und allen anderen
Partnerinnen die für diese Gemeinschaft
sind und gegen den Nationalismus lass
uns das in die Tat umsetzen durch mutige
Debatten und auch den zu widersprechen
die gegen Europa sind vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege der
Abschlussbericht soll dieses Frühjahr
fertig sein als Grund dafür gilt
weiterhin die Präsidentschaftswahl in
Frankreich Amtsinhaber macron hofft mit
dem von ihm angestoßenen
eu-reformprozess Punkt zu können
im Saal Anwesenden Schriftführer uns
fehlen Frauen und Männer zum Auszählen
der stimmzeit im Schriftführer Augen
befinden sich nur wenige Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die alleine wahrscheinlich zwei
bis drei Stunden brauchen würden um die
Ausbildung er war ein vorzunehmen also
die Schriftführer die noch hier sind
würde ich bitten oder die an den
Fernsehschirmen sitzen oder Dom stehen
eine Radiogeräten zuhören bitten doch
sich in den Schriftführer um zu begeben
damit wir frühzeitige Ergebnisse
bekommen
die Schrift früher sind heute gewählt
worden und dann sind sie ja alle
gegangen zum Feiern wo auch immer in der
Tat brauchte Schriftführer um diese 736
stimmen die sein können um auszuziehen
dann werde ich mich akustisch der
merkbar machen aber so dass sie nur mein
klopfen hören und ich werde erst mich
verbal äußern wenn sie drin ist seit
etwas zu weit ausgelegt haben Herr
Kollege klein wird ja sie haben das Wort
keine Sorge herr Präsident keine
Verkehrsdelikte auf meiner Seite wird
der Herr Präsident sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir debattieren
heute über die Konferenz zur Zukunft
Europas eigentlich ist der Titel ja
schon falsch es geht um die Konferenz
zur Zukunft der EU und das ist ein
Unterschied denn sie ist ja eingerichtet
worden von der EU-Kommission das war ja
die Idee von Ursula von der Leyen um den
Status Quo zu erweitern um das was
geranau die Bürger nicht möchten
festzuschreiben unter Schäfer hat es
angesprochen eventuell in ein
Verfassungskonvent zu führen und
deswegen sollten wir uns bevor wir über
die Zukunft reden mal ganz kurz die
Vergangenheit der EU anschauen was ist
denn passiert die EU Brüssel ist hat die
größte Dichte von Lobbyisten weltweit
die EU ist die Institution wo Gelder in
Milliarden Höhe in lobby Interessen
verschoben werden meine Damen und Herren
die EU ist außerdem die Institution die
keine Freiheiten ermöglicht sondern sich
immer neue Zwänge ausdenkt die von Frau
Lühmann angesprochenen Schüleraustausche
die sind zurückgegangen seit es die EU
in dieser Konstitution gibt dafür sind
die Zwänge hochgegangen man hat den
Bürgern die Glühbirnen verboten die
Staubsauger verboten ja und jetzt
verbietet man ihnen sich zu bewegen oder
das zu tun und zu lassen was Sie tun
möchten im nur noch als qr-code-inhaber
ist man ein vollwertiger Mensch das
digitale Kurve Zertifikat auch eine
Erfindung der EU-Kommission meine Damen
und Herren und diese europäischen
Institutionen wie sie sind machen uns
Arm der Euro seit seiner Einführung vor
ziemlich genau 20 Jahren am ersten
Januar 2002 wurde das Bargeld eingeführt
hat in diesem Zeitraum gegenüber der
harten Währung dem Schweizer Franken 35
Prozent verloren und die EZB druckte
Moment zwölfeinhalb Prozent der
Geldmenge jedes Jahr nach meine Damen
und Herren da verwundert es nicht dass
die Leute in der Europäischen Union
nicht mehr wissen wie sie ihr Leben
finanzieren sollen wie sie ihre Miete
finanzieren sollen wie sie sich
überhaupt noch ein Haus kaufen sollen
das geht gar nicht diese Europäische
Union macht die Menschen arm und
deswegen muss man leider feststellen
Europas Zukunft wird nur dann blöd sein
wenn diese Europäische Union keine
Zukunft hat
doch
und das wissen sie das weiß die
EU-Kommission und das wissen die Bürger
auch deswegen haben die Bürger das ja
als es um die Abstimmung über die
europäische Verfassung ging abgelehnt
und um das Problem zu umgehen hat man
diese Konferenz zur Zukunft Europas
erfunden die sogenannte
partizipative Demokratie das Versprechen
Bürger werden beteiligt können mitreden
und sie werden gehört Frau Lührmann hat
sie vorhin erzählt die Wahrheit das ist
ein Plenum mit Abgeordneten drinnen und
dann mit angeblich zufällig ausgewählten
Bürgern wie sind die ausgewählt worden
hinterfragen wir das mal da saß kein
Notar und hat Personalausweisnummern
gezogen sondern das hat Kanta gemacht
eine Organisation die in Millionenhöhe
Zuwendungen von der Europäischen Union
bekommt und die übrigens den Mantel des
Schweigens darüber hüllt wie diese Leute
ausgewählt worden sind und wenn man
denen ein bisschen hinterher
recherchiert dann merkt man das sind
alles überzeugte föderalistinnen und
Föderalisten Mitglieder von NGOs die
Vereinigte Staaten von Europa fordern
also genau das was die Bürger Europas
eigentlich nicht wollen sind diese
Bürger die Sie in dieses Plenum
hineingesetzt haben und jetzt spiegeln
sie den Leuten vor
jetzt spiegeln sie den Leuten vor diese
Zivilgesellschaft das seien die Bürger
die die Interessen der Bürger vertreten
das ist einfach nur falsch meine Damen
und Herren die Zivilgesellschaft
vertritt nicht die Zivilisten nicht die
Bürger sondern sie vertritt knallhart
genau die Lobby-Interessen weshalb die
Bürger ja eben genau kritisch über
Brüssel denken weshalb sie Brüssel
ablehnen weshalb sie die Europäische
Union ablehnen keiner will Lobbyisten
jeder will Demokratie und sie zerstören
die Demokratie mit solchen Aktionen
meine Damen und Herren
und an dieser Stelle möchte ich Sie
bitten haben Sie den Mut die Bürger hier
nicht zu betrügen haben Sie den Mut
wirklich in den Dialog mit den Bürgern
zu treten haben Sie den Mut direkte
Demokratie zu wagen wenn sie das nicht
tun
dann dele geht definieren Sie genau die
Institutionen die wir eigentlich
erhalten wollten die Institutionen die
die Demokratie und die Regierung tragen
aber auch die Demokratie an sich denn
wenn die Bürger belogen werden dann
können Sie das Eine vom Anderen nicht
mehr unterscheiden und das wird
auffliegen Europa hat nur dann eine
blühende Zukunft wenn diese Europäische
Union keine Zukunft hat haben sie recht
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
nächster Redner ist der Kollege Thomas
Hacker FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen so
unterschiedlich können die Sichtweisen
sein die zu treffenden Worte des
kürzlich verstorbenen Präsidenten des
Europäischen Parlaments David des
sassuli machen uns die Dimension der
Aufgabe deutlich die vor uns
Europäerinnen und Europäern liegt unsere
Herausforderung ist es eine neue Welt zu
schaffen nicht weniger den
Herausforderungen unserer Gegenwart kann
sich Europa nicht mehr entziehen wie
bewältigen wir die gesundheitlichen
gesellschaftlichen und ökonomischen
Folgen der andauernden Pandemie wie
sichern wir unseren Planeten für
zukünftige Generationen ohne Wohlstand
und sozialen Frieden zu gefährden und
wie reagieren wir auf die Aggressionen
an unseren Außengrenzen gegen unsere
Nachbarn und auf Angriffe auf unsere
demokratischen Werte die Antworten
werden wir nur gemeinsam finden und nur
im Dialog
die Zukunft
die Konferenz zur Zukunft Europas ist
eine große Chance vielleicht sogar eine
historische sie ist geliebtes Europa sie
ermöglicht Begegnung und Austausch und
natürlich auch der Auseinandersetzung
mit neuen Perspektiven ja es ist ein
Experiment die liberativer Demokratie
aber dieses Experiment schafft eine neue
europäische Öffentlichkeit eine
europäische Öffentlichkeit die er längst
Realität ist die grenzüberschreitend
denkt lebt arbeitet studiert und liebt
der Motor der Konferenz hatte
staatsschwierigkeiten nicht jedes der
beteiligten Länder ist schon jetzt von
ihrem Erfolg überzeugt trotz des
zögerlichen Starts wegen der Pandemie
und einer langen Diskussion über die
Besetzung des exekutivgremiums erleben
wir zurzeit eine lebendige Debatte 5000
Veranstaltungen
350.000 Teilnehmer 13.000 digital
eingereichte Zukunftsideen das ist
geliebte Demokratie
wir erleben es in den Bürger vor und
unser Europa ist in Menschen nicht egal
sie wollen sich an der Debatte über die
Zukunft über die Ausrichtung unseres
Kontinents beteiligen sie wollen ein
handlungsfähiges Europa das seine
demokratischen Werte verteidigt schauen
wir auf die Ergebnisse der Bürger vor
und die Bürger wollen die
rechtsstaatlichkeitsverordnung
verschärfen sie wollen dass die
Europawahlen Direktor werden und wollen
Abgeordnete künftig auch über
europäische Listen wählen die Menschen
wollen ein Europa das Entscheidungen
trifft sie fordern zu Recht Lösungen für
die Probleme die das
Einstimmigkeitsprinzip mit sich bringt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen an
Diskurs und Input Mangel es sicher nicht
jetzt kommt es auf jeden einzelnen an
auch hier im Haus für eine kluge
Veränderung Europas zu werden für eine
gute Zukunft dieses großen Projekts dann
haben die Populisten in Warschau oder
Budapest oder auch hier am rechten Rand
und am Balkon keine Argumente mehr für
ihren Kurs gegen Europa ich bin den
Kollegen von der Kriechbaum und Axel
Schäfer sehr dankbar dass sie uns dass
sie den Deutschen Bundestag in der
Plenarsitzung vertreten doch wir alle
gemeinsam tragen Verantwortung dass
dieses Vorhaben zum Erfolg wird die
heutige Debatte ist ein Schritt ein
Schritt für mehr Öffentlichkeit sie ist
aber auch Selbstverpflichtung für uns
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
Empfehlungen zu handlungsprioritäten der
Europapolitik der Bundesrepublik und der
EU werden die mühsame Arbeit in
Vorschläge dürfen nicht wieder in der
Schublade verschwinden Ware
Glaubwürdigkeit braucht Veränderung
unser gemeinsames Europa ist gerade für
die jungendemokratien in unserer
Nachbarschaft eine Inspiration ein
Sehnsuchtsort ein Garant für Friede und
Freiheit ich wünsche mir dass wir auch
Stimmen aus unseren Nachbarländern
miteinbeziehen aus den Ländern führt
deren Jugend die Zukunft in der EU liegt
unsere Regierungskoalition wird zum
Gelingen der Konferenz zur Zukunft
Europas ihren Beitrag leisten wir wollen
unsere europäischen Partner davon
überzeugen dass die Ergebnisse der
Konferenz ehrlich diskutiert werden wir
wollen die notwendigen Reformen zügig
angehen wir wollen dass Sie angestoßenen
Ideen zu einem verfassungsgebenden
Konvent führen der die Grundlage für das
Europa der Zukunft schafft für einen
föderalen europäischen Bundesstaat der
dezentral nach den Grundsätzen der
Subsidiarität und Verhältnismäßigkeit
organisiert ist und der fest und
unverrückbar auf der Grundrechte Kater
Fust vielen Dank
der nächste Rede in der vereinbarten
Debatte zur Konferenz zur Zukunft
Europas ist jetzt André hunko hier noch
schon im Bild der Sprecher für
Europapolitik der Linksfraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
wir reden hier über die Zukunft Europas
über die Zukunftskonferenz Europas und
vorhin haben wir in der Debatte über
Frieden in Europa gesprochen und das
sind zwei getrennte Debatten und ich
glaube dass das falsch ist weil ich
zutiefst davon überzeugt bin dass Europa
nur eine Zukunft hat wenn es ein
friedliches Europa ist
wir werden in diesen Tagen schmerzlich
daran erinnert durch die Situation an
der
Grenze an zwischen Ukraine und Russland
aber auch vielleicht durch die
Entwicklungen auf dem Westbalkan in
Bosnien etwa das eben Europa sehr viel
größer ist als nur die Europäische Union
die Europäische Union hat 27
Mitgliedstaaten zu Europa gehören aber
auch die Staaten des Westbalkans dazu
gehört die Ukraine und Russland dazu
gehört auch Großbritannien oder die
Schweiz und deswegen denke ich dass über
eine über Zukunft von Europa sprechen
auch über einen gesamt europäisches
Projekt reden müssen was auch
Sicherheitsfragen beinhaltet es gibt
neben der Europäischen Union
wichtige europäische
Institutionen die Organisation für
Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa
die OSZE es gibt den Europarat die das
gesamte den gesamten europäischen
Kontinent abbilden und wenn wir aber mal
auf die Proportionen schauen da müssen
wir feststellen dass etwa der Europarat
ein Jahresetat hat was dem tagesetat der
EU entspricht und das zum Beispiel die
OSZE die ja jetzt gerade eigentlich so
wichtig wäre
ein Jahresetat hat dass nur ein 40
dessen ist was gerade beschlossen wurde
auf EU-Ebene nämlich ein neuer
europäischer militärfonds ein
sogenannter verteidigungsfonds und ich
denke das sind falsche Proportionen die
wir korrigieren sollten
bei dieser Konferenz zur Zukunft der EU
so muss man sich ja nennen geht es
natürlich auch um wichtige Themen es ist
angesprochen worden hier
es geht um die Frage dass
Einstimmigkeitsprinzip im bestimmten
Politikfeldern aufzuheben ich halte es
für falsch das in Politikfeld der außen
und der sogenannten Verteidigungspolitik
zu machen weil es würde dazu führen dass
es noch leichter wäre auch
perspektivisch
militärisch zu intervenieren ich wäre
sehr dafür dass Einstimmigkeitsprinzip
etwa im sozial oder im Steuerbereich
aufzuheben damit es einfacher wird zum
Beispiel einen europäischen Mindestlohn
einzuführen damit es einfacher wird auch
große Konzerne zu besteuern die hier
viel zu wenig Steuern zahlen damit man
vielleicht mal auch über eine europäisch
koordinierte Vermögensabgabe reden
könnte oder auch damit die Reform des
dringend die notwendige Reform des
stabilitäts- und wachstumspakts dieser
60 3%-regel umgesetzt werden könnte das
halte ich eigentlich für sehr viel
zielführender
zur Frage
der Zukunft Europa die Konferenz läuft
jetzt noch bis
in den Mai hinein ich habe darauf
hingewiesen dass es wichtig wäre dass
man auch die anderen Institutionen mit
einbindet auch
Staaten zum Beispiel Beitrittskandidaten
vom Westbalkan ich würde einen konkreten
Vorschlag machen an unsere zwei
Vertreter hier aus dem Bundestag Herr
Kriechbaum und Herrn Schäfer für die
Abschlusskonferenz könnte man ja etwa
die Parlamentspräsidenten von OSZE und
Europarat einladen um diese Perspektive
die Perspektive des gesamteuropäischen
Friedens mit einzubringen das wäre ein
konkreter Vorschlag vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
also ein interessanter Vorschlag von
André hunko hier Sprecher für
Europapolitik der Linksfraktion und der
nächste Redner im Parlament ist Anton
Hofreiter von den Bündnisgrünen und er
ist jetzt mittlerweile Vorsitzender des
Ausschusses für die Angelegenheiten der
Europäischen Union
ihr wart doch schon mal nah dran
insofern
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist einfach
sehr sehr gut für die Zukunft der
Europäischen Union dass die Konferenz
zur Zukunft Europas so erfolgreich
arbeitet entscheidend ist jetzt dass
möglichst vieles davon auch umgesetzt
wird was sich die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
vorstellen denn
wir brauchen eine handlungsfähige
Europäische Union
denn die Probleme sind häufig
transnational und wenn ich mir die
Länder Europas anschaue
sind die Probleme im Vergleich zu
Ländern selbst großen europäischen
Ländern wie Frankreich oder Deutschland
riesig es glaubt doch nicht ernsthaft
irgendjemand das mit den
Herausforderungen der Globalisierung mit
den Herausforderungen ökonomisch
erfolgreicher Mächte allerdings
hochgradig autoritären aggressiv
auftretender Mächte wie China die
einzelnen europäischen Länder alleine
klarkommen werden das wird uns nur
gelingen diesen Herausforderungen
beizukommen wenn die Europäische Union
handlungsfähiger wird wenn schneller zu
Entscheidungen gekommen wird und wenn
die europäischen Länder solidarischer
sind und dafür haben die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger weil sie sich ein
handlungsfähiges Europa wünschen
hervorragende Vorschläge gemacht und
jetzt kommt es darauf an dass wir dass
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland dass
unsere Bundesregierung alles dafür tut
dass möglichst vieles davon auch
Realität
und wenn man sich die Umfragen auch in
Deutschland anschaut haben die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger laut Umfragen
erst vor kurzem wieder angemerkt dass
die Klimakrise einen der größten laut
der Umfrage die größte Herausforderung
für die Europäische Union ist und auch
dafür brauchen wir eine handlungsfähige
Europäische Union und ich bin ehrlich
gesagt heilfroh dass wir jetzt die
Bundesregierung haben die alles tun wird
um die EU-Kommission darf zu
unterstützen dass das fit for fifty-five
Paket wo es um realen Klimaschutz geht
auch wirklich umgesetzt wird und nicht
eingebremst wird und verwässert wird und
ich glaube auch dass hier bei uns im
Parlament darauf ankommt dass wir alles
dafür tun dass in der französischen
Ratspräsidentschaft das in den nächsten
Monaten möglichst vieles davon umgesetzt
wird denn die Klimakrise wir müssen nach
auch auf nationaler Ebene vieles aber
die Klimakrise kriegen wir nur im Griff
wenn wir europäisch und international
handeln und da ist auch entscheidend
dass wir an Frankreich Seite stehen eine
möglichst praktikable Lösung zu finden
für das was sich die französische
Ratspräsidentschaft vorgenommen hat
nämlich einen funktionierenden
co2-grenzausgleich der sowohl
klimapolitisch als auch ökonomisch als
auch in Zusammenarbeit mit einem
Partnerinnen und Partnern funktioniert
denn was ist
co2-grenzausgleich kompliziertes Wort
aber wenn in China als Beispiel Stahl
sehr co2-reich hergestellt wird und in
einem europäischen Land Stahl sehr CO2
Arm hergestellt wird kann es nicht sein
dass daraus ein Wettbewerbsnachteil wird
sondern wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
Regeln so sind dass die Unternehmen die
CO2-frei produzieren am Ende davon auch
wirklich Ökonom profitieren damit der
Kampf gegen die Klimakrise sowohl
international funktioniert als auch
ökonomisch funktioniert nämlich dann
wird eine große Vorbildwirkung entfalten
und was sich die Bürger und Bürger auch
gewünscht haben es dass wir die Werte
nach innen verteidigen und da ist der
Punkt Rechtsstaatlichkeit angesprochen
auch da glaube ich wird man in den
nächsten Monaten mehr tun und auch da
gibt es klare Wünsche und Vorstellungen
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger und deshalb
gilt es auch dies umzusetzen ich freue
mich auf die nächsten Monate und Jahre
und jetzt kommt es darauf an möglichst
viel aus den guten Vorschlägen zu machen
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr Hofreiter
als nächste Redner nennt das Wort die
Kollegin Dr klein zu ihrer ersten
Parlamentsrede
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Europa ist unsere Zukunft Europa ist
unser Schicksal diese Feststellung
unseres verstorbenen altbundeskanzlers
Helmut Kohl ist ebenso
geschichtsträchtig wie zukunftsweisend
über 77 Jahre lang war die europäische
Integration ein Garant für Frieden
Freiheit und Wohlstand
gemeinsam haben wir Europäer nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg Europa wieder
aufgebaut
gemeinsam haben wir den Kalten Krieg und
so manche Krise überwunden
stets hat mir dabei die Zukunft eines
geeinten Europas vor Augen
und wie die Generationen vor uns stehen
wir auch heute wieder vor der Frage wie
muss eine Europäische Union beschaffen
sein die das Versprechen von Frieden
Demokratie Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
Freiheit auch zukünftig garantieren kann
wie beantworten wir die großen Fragen
unserer Zeit wir auf den Klimawandel
reagieren wie die Digitalisierung von
Alltag Wirtschaft und Verwaltung
vorantreiben wie dem demografischen
Wandel begegnen wie die Migration im
europäischen Konsens steuern wie bleiben
wir wirtschaftlich wettbewerbsfähig und
politisch relevant auf der
internationalen Bühne darauf Antworten
zu finden auch das ist das Ziel der
Konferenz zur Zukunft Europas
und für eine Europa das weiter
zusammenwächst und auch zusammensteht
müssen die Europäerinnen und Europäer
diesem müssen sie sich wieder in diesem
Vorhaben wiederfinden und der Kollege
hat es schon gesagt das ist ein ganz
vielversprechendes Zeichen des bislang
360.000 Menschen an rund 5.000
Veranstaltungen teilgenommen und mehr
als
13.000 unterschiedliche Ideen
eingebracht haben
wir als
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion begrüßen
diese breite Beteiligung und dieses
große Engagement ganz ausdrücklich denn
eins ist klar
europäischer Geist entsteht nicht durch
Bürokratie und durch
regulierungsempfehlungen
er entsteht und greifbaren wenn Menschen
konkret von der EU profitieren wenn sie
sie als Chance wenn Sie sie als
Bereicherung wahrnehmen
die europäische Idee ist nur so stark
wie ihr Rückhalt innerhalb der
Bevölkerung der Mitgliedstaaten ist wir
dürfen nicht zulassen dass ein Gefühl
der Distanz zwischen Brüssel und den
Sorgen und Nöten der Menschen vor Ort
entsteht und die Bürgerkonferenz leistet
dazu ein ganz wichtigen Beitrag wir
haben vorhin schon ein paar Vorschläge
und Forderungen gehört am letzten
Wochenende hat die Konferenz ja wieder
stattgefunden mit den Bürgerforen und da
wurden mehr Kitaplätze gefordert
Sicherheit im Netz verständliche
Datenschutzbestimmungen aber auch mehr
demokratiebildung und sogar die
Umbenennung der EU-Institutionen also
wir sehen wir haben ganz breite
Vorschläge die da eingebracht werden
klar ist die EU ist immer dort gefordert
wo wir als starke Gemeinschaft mehr
erreichen können die gemeinsame
Handelspolitik ist ein ganz handfestes
Beispiel dafür aber auch gemeinsame
Investitionen und Forschung in Forschung
und Innovation
die Stärke Europas war aber auch immer
die Einheit in Vielfalt der permanente
Wettbewerb hat uns nach innen und nach
außen stark gemacht und das ist auch gut
so denn im globalen wirtschaftlichen
Wettbewerb insbesondere mit Blick auf
die USA China und Indien können
Nationalstaaten alleine nur schwer
bestehen
und gleichzeitig brauchen wir aber auch
wir wieder mehr Mut zu Subsidiarität und
Eigenverantwortung für an einiges Europa
brauchen wir Strukturen die nach innen
einen Mehrwert schaffen und nach außen
Handlungsfähigkeit gewährleisten und
dafür müssen wir auch selbstkritisch
bestehende Strukturen hinterfragen und
überprüfen
vor allem müssen wir aber dafür sorgen
dass sich die Stimmen der Europäerinnen
und Europäer gehört werden und auch
dieses Haus steht in der Verantwortung
darauf zu achten dass die Vorschläge der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Eingang in die
Initiativen der EU finden
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ist überzeugt
dass die Konferenz der Zukunft Europa
eine große Chance sein kann sie kann ein
Auftakt für eine neue Erzählung von
Europa sein eine Erzählung die die
vielen Stimmen der Bürger Europas ins
Zentrum rückt eine Erzählung die den
Kopf überzeugt und das Herz berührt die
Zukunft eines starken und geeinten
Europas das sind wir unseren Kindern
schuldig aber auch den Generationen die
dieses Europa aufgebaut haben wir als
cdu/csu Bundestagsfraktionen sind bereit
vielen Dank
klein mit ihrer ersten rede hier vor dem
Hohen Hause für die CDU sie ist mit dem
Ausschuss für die Angelegenheiten der
Europäischen Union der nächste Redner
kommt von der SPD Fabian Funke und auch
er ist hier neu im Hause und heute mit
seiner ersten Rede dran auch erst
Mitglied im Ausschuss für die
Angelegenheit der Europäischen Union
Fabian Funke SPD
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen für meine
Generation ist die EU mehr als nur eine
abstrakte Struktur oder eine politische
Organisation oder die Summe von
Verwaltungsakten die EU ist ein längst
nicht mehr wegzudenkender Teil unseres
eigenen Lebens geworden meine Generation
kennt Europa gar nicht anders sie ist
aufgewachsen mit offenen Grenzen mit
starken Austausch zwischen den Regionen
mit Schüleraustauschen erasmusssemestern
einer gemeinsamen Währung und eines
gemeinsamen Arbeits- und
Wirtschaftsraums
wir können und wollen es uns gar nicht
mehr anders vorstellen als dieses
gemeinsame Europa unter dem Dach der
Europäischen Union sie ist unser Zuhause
und meines besonders als jemand der in
einer Grenzregion zu Tschechien wohnt
und aufgewachsen ist und sieht wie diese
Länder immer mehr zusammenwachsen wie
Freundschaften entstehen wie Menschen
auf Arbeit pendeln und alles immer enger
wird Thema dieser Debatte ist aber auch
die Zukunft der Europäischen Union und
unsere Generation wird die Zukunft der
Europäischen Union sein und sind wir
doch mal ehrlich es ist nicht alles gut
in der Europäischen Union die EU steht
vor großen Herausforderungen und auch
Bedrohungen die die Zukunft Europas ja
auch in den Mittelpunkt die Konferenz
stellt wir müssen entschlossen und
gemeinsam beim Klimaschutz Vorgehen wir
müssen große Investitionen in Zukunft
Technologien und Infrastruktur
voranbringen einerseits um die
Klimakrise zu bekämpfen andererseits
aber natürlich auch um gute Arbeit in
ganz Europa zu sichern und die
Wirtschaft fit für die Zukunft zu machen
das Programm fit so fifty five der
Europäischen Kommission war dazu ein
guter Aufschlag den es jetzt gilt auch
mit Leben zu füllen und da sind wir auch
als Bundesrepublik Deutschland als
Wirtschafts- und bevölkerungsstärkstes
Land in großer Verantwortung aber auch
darüber hinaus müssen wir gemeinsam
dafür streiten dass die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit in Europa nicht
weiter von nationalistinnen und
Nationalisten beispielsweise in Polen
und Ungarn unterminiert wird und dass
die europäischen Werte für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger auch als
europäische Rechte erlebbar und sicher
werden
und das bedeutet auch ganz klar weil die
Verantwortung endet ja nicht an den
europäischen Außengrenzen wir müssen das
Sterben im Mittelmeer beenden wir müssen
Europa auf den Weg zu einer
menschenwürdigen aufnahmenpolitik
bringen die die Menschen im Mittelmeer
rettet und die humanitären Standards
unserer Union an den Außengrenzen
sichert
Situationen wie in Moria oder an der
polnisch belarussischen Grenze dürfen
nicht unser Anspruch sein die
Europäische Union muss nach innen und
nach außen ihre humanitären
demokratischen und rechtsstaatlichen
Ansprüchen gerecht werden sie darf sich
nicht von autokratischen Drittstaaten
mit Migrationsströmen erpressbar machen
sie darf nicht hartenlos dabei zusehen
wie Mitgliedsstaaten demokratische
Grundwerte Stück zu Stück zurückrollen
und sie muss in der Außen- und
Sicherheitspolitik handlungsfähig sein
das sehen wir gerade mal wieder
besonders kurzum wir brauchen
europäische Souveränität und deswegen
ist es auch sehr sehr gut und ich freue
mich sehr dass die französische
Ratspräsidentschaft das jetzt in den
Mittelpunkt stellt und Dinge wie der
Austritt des Vereinigten Königreich
zeigen uns schmerzlich wie fragil die
Europäische Union auch sein kann und
auch in den anderen Ländern machen sich
Nationalisten bereit die unsere
Vorstellung des gemeinsamen Lebens in
der Europäischen Union in Frage stellen
und da bin ich insbesondere froh dass in
diesem Haus zumindest unter den meisten
Fraktionen mit expliziter Ausnahme
dieser Fraktion hier rechts im Parlament
eine große Einigkeit darüber besteht
dass wir die Europäische Union brauchen
und weiterentwickeln müssen um noch
enger zusammen zu wachsen
und deshalb müssen wir in der
Europäischen Union noch stärker
zueinander finden weiter zusammenwachsen
und die Bürgerinnen und Bürger auf dem
Weg aber da auch mitnehmen weil nur mit
Beteiligungen Akzeptanz schaffen wir
weiteres Wohlbefinden für die weitere
Integration der Europäischen Union und
damit bin ich auch sehr sehr froh dass
dieser Prozess zur Zukunft der
Europäischen Union in so einer breiten
Diskussion zwischen Rat Kommission
Parlament und mit den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern da draußen in diesem Land
stattfindende und man findet man kann
die Ergebnisse können sich auch sehen
lassen
wir müssen aber auch die
parlamentarische Beteiligung in der
Europäischen Union stärken wir brauchen
eine Reform des Europäischen Parlaments
und transnationale Listen das ist ja
auch das was die Menschen da draußen
fordern
die Zukunft der Bundesrepublik muss eine
europäische sein um die Herausforderung
einer globalisierten Welt meistens zu
können lassen Sie uns also gemeinsam
daran arbeiten und dafür sorgen dass
meine und zukünftige Generationen in
einem vereinten souverän und gerechten
Europa aufwachsen können vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Fabian viel
Applaus auch für ihn und seine erste
Rede hier in der Debatte zur Konferenz
zur Zukunft Europas die Ergebnisse
sollen im Mai vorgelegt werden
sitzungspräsidium oder
sitzungsdienstachten sehr genau dass
diejenigen die nicht von der
maskenpflicht befreit sind auch ihre
Masken tragen wir sind für jeden Hinweis
dankbar aber es muss nicht jeder Hinweis
erfolgen
nächster Redner wird der Kollege Browser
weil von der afd-fraktion sein der von
der Tribüne spricht wo unser weil sie
kennen das Spiel nicht wenn ihr Redezeit
sich am Ende nähert bekommen sie zwei
Minuten vor Schluss eine optische Signal
die Redezeit läuft dann runter sie haben
das Wort Harald weil der
europapolitische Sprecher der AFD die
von macron init der Zukunftskonferenz
soll ja direkt zulaufen auf einen neuen
Verfassungskonvent mit der
Verschlimmbesserung das qualifizierte
mehrheitsentscheide die letzten
vetomöglichkeiten verhindern sollen es
geht hierbei vor allem um Außenpolitik
und Steuerhoheit mit zeitgemäßer
panikrhetorik in einfacher Sprache also
Klima Corona Russland China und so
weiter im ampelkoalitionsvertrag steht
sogar einigermaßen verfassungswidrig die
Gründung eines eu-bundesstaates und
durch den Abgang Großbritanniens hat
sich die Sache mit dem Veto ja schon von
selbst erledigt längst sind die
Nettozahler in der qualifizierten
Minderheit angekommen mit der
augenwischerischen Zukunftskonferenz
wird hier nur ein eu-mäßiges weiter so
verschleiert der englische Erfinder des
Nation Branding Simon Arnold redet der
Ende 2011 vor Brüsseler berufseuropäern
zu den Grenzen von Werbung und
Propaganda
die EU
Kommunikationsstrategie zeichnen sich
demnach dadurch aus dass sie Zitat
erstens Informationen verbreitet nach
denen keiner fragt zweitens Werbung
betreibt obwohl sie kein Produkt hat
drittens nicht weiß wer ihre Kunden sind
und viertens die ganze Zeit nur
geldverschwenderische Propaganda
betreibt
diese vor sich herlaufende
Zukunftskonferenz nun ist eine besonders
dreiste Suggestion homöopathischer
Bürgerbeteiligung es wird so getan als
ob der ganze Apparat einen echten
änderungswillen hätte es hat den
Charakter eine Art Paartherapie und zwar
nach einer fast 66 Jahre andauernden
Gewalt und Missbrauch Beziehung die fast
nur einseitigen Betrug und Ausbeutung
kennt eine missbrauchbeziehung zwischen
politapparat und zahnenden Publikum
welches immer weniger Leistung für immer
mehr Beitrag bekommt national wie
international das ganze kannte immer nur
eine Richtung nämlich die falsche hier
aber nun unsere glasklarenvorschläge wie
eine wünschenswerte EU Zukunft aussehen
müsste erstens Rückführung des Brüsseler
EP zu einer echtparlamentarischen
Versammlung aller Europarat oder
Französisch deutsche Versammlung mit
maximal der Hälfte der derzeitigen
Abgeordneten bezahlt nach nationalen
Diäten
und alle Abgeordneten haben zu kommen
aus national Verantwortlichen und
gewählten Parlamenten so wie sie auch
die Urform des Geschehens in Brüssel vor
1979 war des Weiteren
Angleichungen der Gehälter nicht in dem
Sinne wie es 2009 erfolgt ist alle
bekommen das gleiche exorbitant
Brüsseler Spitzengehälter sondern es
wird bezahlt nach nationalen Diäten plus
Spesen fertig und drittes und letztes
zunächst die Rückführung des
agrarbereichs in nationale Verantwortung
und Beendigung einer völlig
überdimensionierten Übergriffigkeit im
Finanzbereich und endlich eine klare
überfällige
aufgabenbeschränkung aus der sich alles
Weitere ergibt machen wir uns bitte
sofort auf den Weg in diese gute und
bessere EU Zukunft die beweist dass man
lernt fähig und lernwillig ist dieser
Beweis ist zu führen wir stehen bereit
sie offenbar nicht danke
vielen Dank Herr Kollege großer weil
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin Dr an
weruschka Jurisch FDP-Fraktion zu ihrer
ersten Parlament
herr Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
innerhalb der Europäischen Union prägen
Frieden und Wohlstand unser Leben es ist
heute aber erst 77 Jahre her dass das
Konzentrationslager Auschwitz befreit
wurde meine Eltern haben noch als kleine
Kinder das Grauen des von Deutschland
verschuldeten Krieges miterlebt heute
debattieren wir hier über die Konferenz
zur Zukunft Europas heute debattieren
wir wie wir in der EU in Zukunft auch in
Zukunft in Frieden und sozial ökologisch
und wirtschaftlich stabil leben können
in den Foren der Konferenz für die
Zukunft Europas haben sich Menschen sehr
selbstbewusst dafür engagiert Vision zu
entwickeln und Lösungsansätze zu
formulieren ihnen gilt unser großer Dank
und ihren Einsatz für ihre sehr
wertvolle Arbeit
ich möchte hier dafür werben dass wir
auch im Bundestag die Dynamik der
Zukunftskonferenz und der französischen
Ratspräsidentschaft für die
Weiterentwicklung der EU flankieren und
unterstützen Europa ist noch nicht
fertig der Weg zu mehr europäischer
Stärke und Integration führt sowohl über
Reform auf institutioneller Ebene als
auch über mehr Vernetzung zwischen den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern mehr
Wissensaustausch mehr
Informationsaustausch mehr persönliche
Begegnungen darin liegt noch viel
Potenzial für eine innere Stärkung und
weitere Entfaltung der EU
deshalb möchte ich diesen Aspekt der
besseren Vernetzung von Menschen und
Ideen hier und heute besonders in den
Fokus rücken die Teilnehmerinnen und
Teilnehmer der Zukunftskonferenz des
deutschen Forums dieser Konferenz haben
dazu auch einige ganz konkrete
Vorschläge erarbeitet beispielsweise
schlagen Sie vor dass ein EU-weites
Bildungs- und Informationsmedium
einzurichten sei dass eine
Informationsplattform für Best Practice
in der aus- und Weiterbildung aufgesetzt
werden solle und dass der
Schüleraustausch zwischen allen
EU-Ländern intensiviert und unabhängig
vom Einkommen der Eltern gestaltet
werden solle als Europäerin
als Europäerin möchte ich zu mehr
Vernetzung von Menschen und Ideen noch
aus ganz persönlicher Sicht ergänzen
gerade auch die grenznahenräume
innerhalb
Europas also beispielsweise der
Bodenseeregion in der ich lebe verdienen
unsere Aufmerksamkeit wenn ich dort wie
soll es dann zwischen Grenz ferneren
Regionen klappen oft hapert es ja ein
ganz praktischen Dingen der mangelhafte
Ausbau zum Beispiel von
grenzüberschreitenden Verkehrswegen
verhindern den Austausch von Menschen
und Ideen
bürokratische Erschwernisse bei der
grenzüberschreitenden Erbringung von
Dienstleistern verhindern eine
wirtschaftliche Integration und
ungenutztes Potenzial bei der
grenzüberschreitenden Zusammenarbeit von
Institutionen bremsen die volle
Entfaltung von Regionen als
Bundestagsabgeordnete werde ich mich
stark dafür machen dass die
Weiterentwicklung der EU für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger greifbar wird
gerade auch durch mehr Vernetzung von
Menschen und Ideen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben sich mit
vielen wegweisenden und auch ganz
praktischen Ideen an der europäischen
Zukunftskonferenz beteiligt wirken auch
wir hier im Bundestag daraufhin dass sie
Ergebnisse der Konferenz für eine
umfassende Weiterentwicklung genutzt
werden bis hin zu den vertraglichen
Grundlagen der Europäischen Union genau
das ist eine zentrale europapolitische
Forderung in unserem
ampelkoalitionsvertrag und als Liberale
freue ich mich darüber sehr
ich möchte meine erste Rede in diesem
Haus nicht enden ohne Danke zu sagen
Danke für ihr europäisches Parlament
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger für ein
starkes vernetztes und demokratisches
Europa als Liberale und freie Demokratin
erfüllt mich der Frieden innerhalb der
EU in mit großer Dankbarkeit die
aktuelle Lage zeigt uns dass dieser
Friede keine Selbstverständlichkeit ist
lassen sie uns jeden Tag und überall
weiter daran arbeiten vielen Dank
diskutiert über die Zukunftskonferenz
zur Zukunft Europas da soll es ja sogar
Debatten geben gibt es auch schon
eigentlich vor Ort ursprünglich geplant
viel ist jetzt ins Netz verlegt wegen
Corona natürlich
also ich mache das als allgemeine
Anregung und das nächste Mal spreche ich
Persönlichkeiten unmittelbar an nächster
Redner wo ich noch gar nicht aufgerufen
hatte aber schon da ist der Kollege
Robin Wagner Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Herr Präsident sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Friede der Welt kann nicht gewahrt
werden ohne schöpferische ansprengung
Anstrengungen die der Größe der
Bedrohungen entsprechen
mit diesem Satz hat der damalige
französische Außenminister Robert
Schumann am 9 mai 1950 den Grundstein
für das größte Friedensprojekt aller
Zeiten gelegt die Europäische Union
dass wir heute am Tag des Gedenkens an
die Opfer des Nationalsozialismus über
die Zukunft Europas diskutieren das ist
für mich von großer Bedeutung
wir alle wissen welche unermessliches
Leid die Shoa und der zweite Weltkrieg
für Millionen von Menschen bedeutet hat
und teilweise bis heute bedeutet wir
alle wissen dass aus dieser historischen
Schuld auch immer eine besondere
Verantwortung Deutschlands für die
Zukunft Europas und für ein friedliches
Miteinander erwachsen wird innerhalb der
Europäischen Union haben wir den Frieden
durch eine immer engere Zusammenarbeit
durch friedliches zusammenwachsen über
Grenzen hinweg gesichert für uns ist
Frieden heute gelebte
Selbstverständlichkeit
in ganz Europa und in unserer direkten
Nachbarschaft ist es das nicht bis heute
ist der Frieden auf dem Westbalkan
brüchig bis heute sind dort mancherorts
Menschen an der Macht die den Genozid
von es ribbenitzer leugnen oder
verharmlosen seit 2014 erleben wir an
den Krieg in der Ostukraine und den
Belarus zählen wir heute 1.000
politische Gefangene
1.000 Menschen die für ihren Kampf für
Demokratie mit der Freiheit bezahlen ein
trauriger Rekord ich habe selbst eine
Patenschaft übernommen für ihre
positionellen Journalisten 29 Jahre alt
er hat eine dreijährige Tochter
[Musik]
konnte nicht miterleben wie seine
Tochter Paulina laufen lernte er konnte
nicht miterleben wie sie sprechen lernte
weil er mehr als die Hälfte ihres Lebens
im Gefängnis sitzt unschuldig
und es sind diese individuellen
Geschichten von Menschen die uns vor
Augen führen wie wichtig es ist uns für
Demokratie und Rechtsstaatlichkeit
einzusetzen innerhalb
[Applaus]
und das innerhalb der Europäischen Union
wo wir uns weiter mit ganzer Energie
dafür einsetzen werden die Werte der EU
Demokratie Rechtsstaatlichkeit
Menschlichkeit auch selbst zu leben und
das in allen Politikfeldern mit einem
klaren Kompass
aber eben auch in der europäischen
Nachbarschaft die Menschen in Bosnien
und Herzegowina in der Ukraine in
Belarus sie zählen auf uns und auch
deshalb wird die Koalition ein
besonderes Augenmerk auf diese Region
legen und den Menschen in ihrem Einsatz
für Frieden Demokratie und
Rechtsstaatlichkeit
ich freue mich sehr dass die Konferenz
zur Zukunft der Europäischen Union sich
mit der Rolle der EU in der Welt
beschäftigt und dabei wird
beispielsweise intensiv über eine
häufigere Anwendung von qualifizierten
Mehrheitsentscheidungen in der
Außenpolitik diskutiert und das klingt
erstmal technisch aber es hat sehr
konkrete Auswirkungen denn das bedeutet
dass das Veto eines einzelnen Staates
nicht mehr die komplette
Handlungsfähigkeit der EU lahmlegen kann
die Zukunftskonferenz ist eine
einzigartige Chance mit vielen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern ins Gespräch zu
kommen nutzen wir sie nutzen wir sie für
eine Stärkung des Parlaments für eine
weitere intensive Bürgerbeteiligung
nutzen wir sie um die Uhr noch EU noch
handlungsfähiger strategisch souveräner
und noch stärker zu einem Europa der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu machen vielen
Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Wagner
der europapolitische Sprecher der Grünen
Fraktionen war das die Konferenz zur
Zukunft Europas sollte ja ursprünglich
zwei Jahre dauern allerdings wurde der
Staat verschoben trotzdem bleibt es
dabei der Abschlussbericht soll dieses
Frühjahr fertig sein von daher werden
wir im Frühjahr hier wohl noch weitere
Debatten dazu hören jetzt aber erst
einmal Tobias Winkler für die
Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Konferenz zur Zukunft Europas ist mit
dem Rückenwind gestartet aus der letzten
Europawahl 2019 sind über 200 Millionen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger an die Wahlurne
gegangen und haben dem Europäischen
Parlament ihre Stimme verliehen
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger die spüren
dass sie dieses Europa mitgestalten
müssen mitgestalten wollen Europa ist
gegründet von mutigen Politikern von
Vordenkern Robert Schumann Chamonix
viele wurden hier auch heute schon
genannt später auch Helmut Kohl auch
Angela Merkel Jean Claude Juncker viele
die dieses Europa stark vorangebracht
haben und ich habe den Eindruck dass die
Politiker die vorgedacht haben die die
Menschen mitgenommen haben
heutzutage etwas weniger Mut haben und
von den Menschen getrieben werden die
Menschen wollen mehr und ein stärkeres
und ein demokratischeres Europa und
deswegen freue ich mich Frau
Staatsministerin Lühmann Lühmann dass
sie sagen wir wollen die Ergebnisse
dieser Konferenz ernst nehmen ich habe
auch hier in meine kurzen Zugehörigkeit
zu diesem Hause schon gibt die besondere
Gabe von Abgeordneten auch von
Regierungsmitgliedern das Sonntagsreden
auch unter der Woche gehalten werden
können ich hoffe sehr sehr dass die
Ernsthaftigkeit mit der die Ergebnisse
des Konferenz zur Zukunft Europas
behandelt werden nicht zu dieser
Kategorie gehören sondern dass wir uns
damit auseinandersetzen was die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in den vielen
Foren diskutieren und an Ideen
einbringen
die Zahlen wurden schon genannt
350 über 350.000 Bürgern und Bürgerinnen
die sich beteiligt haben in über 5000
Veranstaltungen ich finde es etwas
schade aber es bleibt noch Zeit
sozusagen jetzt als Kritik aber auch als
Ermutigung dass das Europäische
Parlament und die Europäische Kommission
sehr sehr viel in diesen Prozess
einbringen die diese Bürger Foren mit
organisieren die Veranstaltungen mit
organisieren die viele Partner aus der
Zivilgesellschaft auch animieren und
unterstützen bei ihrer Arbeit die
Bundesregierung aber auch die Länder wie
es auch heute schon angesprochen wurden
wurde sind noch nicht auf diesen Zug
aufgesprungen das was bisher organisiert
wurde reicht noch nicht den Menschen in
Deutschland und in vielen anderen
Ländern ist in der überwiegend großen
Mehrheit nicht bekannt was für ein
großartiges was für ein
zukunftsweisendes Projekt direkter
Bürgerbeteiligung hier ins Leben gerufen
wurden wir müssen wenn wir mehr Menschen
daran beteiligen wollen dann müssen wir
das auf allen Ebenen spielen wir haben
wenn das Ende der Konferenz mit dem
Schlussbericht um den Europatag zum 9
mai stattfinden soll zumindest unter
französischer Ratspräsidentschaft noch
einige Monate Zeit ich glaube es wäre an
es wäre angebracht wenn die
Bundesregierung und die Länder hier
nochmal einen Schub reinsetzen und noch
mal die Bürgerinnen und Bürger animieren
an der Konferenz teilzunehmen und für
diese Verben
wir erleben dass jetzt in der auch in
der heutigen Diskussion viele der Ideen
die die BürgerInnen und Bürgerinnen
einbringen schon vereinnahmt werden zu
politischen Forderungen die dann hier
noch mal
noch mal zu Papier gebracht werden oder
in der in der Rede vorgebracht werden
das ist glaube ich nicht der Punkt wie
wir damit umgehen sollen wir sollten die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ermutigen wir
dürfen mit unseren Ideen
selbstverständlich die Diskussion mit
beeinflussen wir dürfen auch die ganz
konkret an diesen
an diesem Konferenzen mit teilnehmen
aber wir sollten nicht sozusagen unsere
Ideen
dann mit einem mit der Rechtfertigung
dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger dies
alles gefordert hätten durchbringen
sondern wir müssen auf die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger hören und daraus unsere
Schlüsse ziehen ich sehe in dieser
Konferenz zur Zukunft Europas eine
großartige Chance und ich hoffe dass wir
sie auch künftig als solche wahrnehmen
und so behandeln vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege hat hier noch
einmal darauf hingewiesen wie mit den
Ideen mit den Vorschlägen der
Zukunftskonferenz umgegangen werden soll
eine Verpflichtung zur Umsetzung dieser
Reformvorschläge gibt es nicht das heißt
wir werden sehen inwieweit diese Ideen
dann auch Gehör finden bei den
Entscheidungsträgern Johannes Schraps
jetzt für die SPD sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen eine gut
funktionierende Demokratie beruht in
erster Linie auf Vertrauen Vertrauen
durch Mitspracherecht und durch
Mitsprache Möglichkeiten
ein Mitspracherecht haben wir als
Staatsbürger in den europäischen
Demokratien ganz automatisch
aber nicht alle wissen immer so ganz
genau wie sie das wie sie dieses Recht
auch sinnvoll ausüben können deshalb
müssen immer wieder Möglichkeiten zur
Mitsprache geschaffen und aber immer
wieder auch neue Wege gegangen werden
wenn man ein konkretes Anliegen hat dann
kann man sich beispielsweise an seinen
örtlichen Bundestagsabgeordneten wenden
wie es erfreulich viele Menschen tun
oder man kann das parlamentarische
Petitionsrecht nutzen die Mitglieder des
Petitionsausschusses kümmern sich sehr
sorgfältig darum oder man kann im Rahmen
der europäischen der man kann sich im
Rahmen der Konferenz zur Zukunft Europas
beteiligen denn auch sie ist ein solcher
Weg die eigene Meinung einzubringen und
mitzusprechen und sie ist wie wir von
unseren beiden TeilnehmerInnen des
Bundestages Gunter Kriechbaum und Axel
Schäfer gehört haben ein guter und
erfolgreicher Weg liebe Kolleginnen
neben der Einbindung der
Zivilgesellschaft und dem intensiven
Austausch von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
aus allen Teilen des Kontinents zu
zahlreichen Themen bietet die
Zukunftskonferenz aber auch uns
Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentariern
die Möglichkeit unseren Kurs in
bestimmten Fragestellungen nochmal zu
überprüfen und hier möchte ich als
konkretes Beispiel auch noch mal auf das
Stichwort Rechtsstaatlichkeit eingehen
viele Vorredner und Vorrednerinnen haben
es zu Recht angesprochen noch mich hat
dieses Thema in den letzten Jahren hier
im Bundestag intensiv beschäftigt auch
bei der Zukunftskonferenz setzt sich
eine Arbeitsgruppe mit Werten und
rechten mit Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
Sicherheit in Europa auseinander neben
den Diskussionen zwischen den zufällig
ausgewählten Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
Vertretern der Zivilgesellschaft und
Abgeordneten aus den verschiedensten
politischen Ebenen wurden auch tausende
Beiträge von BürgerInnen und Bürgerinnen
und zu diesem Thema auf der
Online-Plattform der Zukunftskonferenz
erfasst und ich finde die Ergebnisse
dieser Beiträge ungemein beeindruckend
Kolle Alpaka hat es vorhin auch schon
angesprochen eine ganz große Gruppe von
teilnehmenden fordert sehr deutlich die
Achtung der Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
einen besseren Schutz der Grundwerte in
der Europäischen Union in manchen
Beiträgen werden beispielsweise sehr
große Bedenken hinsichtlich der
Einhaltung rechtsstaatlicher Kriterien
beispielsweise mit Blick auf Ungarn und
Polen geäußert Bedenken gegenüber
Staatsformen die sich selbst als
illiberal bezeichnen
andererseits muss man auch konstatieren
das ist einige Beiträge gibt die dazu
auffordern die nationalen
Angelegenheiten dieser Länder zu
respektieren da wird beispielsweise auf
das demokratische Recht Ungarns
verwiesen seine Grenzen zu verteidigen
seine christliche Religion Kultur oder
auch eine homogene Gesellschaft
dabei waren einige teilnehmende schlagen
vor die finanzielle Unterstützung für
Länder zu kürzen die gegen gemeinsame
rechtsstaatskriterien verstoßen Ihnen
das Stimmrecht im Europäischen Rat zu
entziehen oder sogar ihre Mitgliedschaft
in der Europäischen Union zu beenden es
wird debattiert ob der Europäische
Gerichtshof die Rolle eines Wächters
über Demokratie und Rechtsstaatlichkeit
in der EU übernehmen soll und auch wie
der haushaltsschutzmechanismus genutzt
werden soll um Regierungen die gegen
europäische Grundwerte verstoßen besser
sanktionieren zu können außerdem wird
ein überprüfungsmechanismus für
Demokratie Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
Grundrechte in der EU gefordert es wird
also intensivst über verschiedene
Standpunkte diskutiert ebenso wie wir
das als Parlamentarierinnen und
Parlamentarier in den Ausschüssen oder
eben hier im Plenum tun
abgesehen davon dass die
konditionalitätsregelung zum Schutz des
EU-Haushaltes für die wir viele Jahre
lang hart hier im Bundestag kämpfen
mussten und die wir während der
deutschen EU-Ratspräsidentschaft endlich
implementieren konnten offensichtlich
größtenteils ganz im Sinne der
europäischen Bürgerinnen und Bürger ist
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
abgesehen davon wird für mich eines an
dieser Zukunftskonferenz ganz deutlich
die europäischen Bürgerinnen und Bürger
wollen ein demokratisches Europa eines
dass sie stark nach innen sowie nach
außen vertritt und ganz viele nehmen die
Möglichkeit zur Mitsprache durch ihre
Beteiligung an der Zukunftskonferenz war
noch ist die Zukunftskonferenz nicht
abgeschlossen und natürlich kann eine
solche Konferenz kein Allheilmittel für
alle möglichen übel und Schwierigkeiten
sein mit denen wir ohne Frage auch in
Europa zu kämpfen haben eines ist diese
Konferenz aber ganz sicher sie ist ein
ausgezeichneter Ausgangspunkt um über
unsere gemeinsame Zukunft zu sprechen in
vielen Themenbereichen entscheidende
Weichen zu stellen und die Konferenz wie
wir das auch in unserem
Koalitionsvertrag beschrieben haben für
notwendige Reformen und eine
Weiterentwicklung Europas zu nutzen und
nicht zuletzt
um auch Mitsprache Möglichkeiten das
Mitspracherecht und damit das
demokratische miteinander zu stärken mit
der heutigen Debatte haben wir ebenfalls
unseren Beitrag dazu geleistet vielen
herzlichen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Herr Kollege schreibt
damit beende ich die Aussprache der
Tagesordnungspunkt ist erledigt ich rufe
auf den tagesauspunkt 6 Beratung des
antragsordnungspunkt beschäftigt sich
mit der deutschen
g7-präsidentschaft Deutschland hält
dieses Jahr den Vorsitz der jährlich
rotiert und der soll laut der
Bundesregierung unter dem Motto
Fortschritt für eine gerechte Welt
gestellt werden also Themen wie die
corona-krise Finanzpolitik
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit Bildung
Demokratie und auch die Klimawende
sollen dort angesprochen werden zum
Beispiel sollen die nationalen Programme
aufeinander abgestimmt werden so dass
ein Land was besonders sich für den
Klimaschutz einsetzt nicht
Handelshemmnisse fürchten muss aber auch
aus dem politische Themen wie Russland
Ukraine werden der deutschen
Präsidentschaft bei der G7 werden sie
beschäftigen Alexander Radwan spricht
als erstes für die Unionsfraktion
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
Deutschland hat dieses Jahr
tünnungsgemäß die Präsidentschaft der G7
übernommen der whisly westlichen
wichtigen Industrienationen
demokratischen Nationen
und führt jetzt die Präsidentschaft bei
diesen Staaten in einer sehr sehr
turbulenten Zeit hier ist wichtig
Führung und Orientierung zu geben und
einen gemeinsamen Werte gebundenen Weg
zu finden und neben dem wertgebundenen
Bereich der uns wichtig ist ist auch das
gemeinsam für uns wichtig und die ersten
Erfahrungen in dieser
Legislaturperiode lassen eher das
Gegenteil befürchten mit Blick auf die
Ukraine nehmen die internationalen
Irritationen eher zu über Deutschland
als ab
mein Thema Klima ist es auch so dass man
zwar generell das Klimaziel verfolgt und
hier einen konsensualen Weg in Europa
gehen möchte wenn aber dann eine
Taxonomie entsprechend diskutiert wird
ist der Aufschrei groß und ich finde das
umso bemerkenswerte das ausgerechnet bei
der Taxonomie ist die Grünen waren die
diesen
Entscheidungsprozess ja sehr gut fanden
den ich jemals als demokratisch sehr
fragwürdig gehalten habe nach dem Motto
entsprechende Mehrheiten gegen einen
Vorschlag zu bekommen ist jetzt umso
schwieriger aber ich denke mir das
sollten wir separat bei diesem Thema
diskutieren aber es ist wichtig dabei
den Energiemix in anderen
Mitgliedstaaten entsprechend zu
respektieren
die Thema das Thema CO2 und Klima ist
auch in der G7 ein wichtiges Thema und
darum wünsche ich der Bundesregierung
viel Erfolg eine co2-bepreisung
international
durchzubringen und insbesondere dann
auch eine entsprechenden
ausgleichmechanismus zu verankern zu
diskutieren für die WTO wenn es
entsprechende Import in die Europäischen
Union gibt die dann eben nicht diesen
entsprechenden co2-kosten unterliegen
meine Damen und Herren darum sind diese
Ziele und ich habe mir das Dokument der
deutschen Präsidentschaft angeschaut
sehr wichtig Klima Umwelt soziales
arbeitsstandard das sind alles
Gleichstellung alles sehr wichtige Ziele
aber daneben sollte man die Schritte
gehen die möglich sind
das sind regionale Zusammenschlüsse wir
haben ja die Situation dass dieses Jahr
das Abkommen ATP mit Japan Südkorea den
asienstaaten China Australien und den
und Neuseeland also Staaten mit
unterschiedlichen gesellschaftlichen
Strukturen die aber 30 Prozent der
Wirtschaft und 30 Prozent der
Bevölkerung repräsentieren dass diese ab
diesem Jahr arbeitet
das transpazifische Abkommen ist in
Verhandlungen und auch Großbritannien
und die USA verhandeln mit China meine
Damen und Herren das heißt andere nehmen
regionale Zusammenschlüsse ernst und
versuchen darüber den Welthandel
entsprechend zu beeinflussen und
Standard zu setzen und an der Spitze ist
es China meine Damen und Herren darum
ist es dringend notwendig dass
Deutschland das Europa die Möglichkeiten
nutzt die es hat und da spreche ich dass
mehr Kulturabkommen mit Südamerika
Lateinamerika und insbesondere das
ceta-abkommen mit dem G7 Staat Kanada
dass wir das endlich voranbringen und
meine Appell geht hier insbesondere an
eine Fraktion hier ihren Widerstand
aufzugeben und diesen entsprechenden
Schritt voranzugehen wir haben
wir haben es bei ttip erlebt die Chance
war da die Tür ging zu und dann hatten
wir einen Präsidenten in den USA der
entsprechend der Gegend gegen den
internationalen Handel gearbeitet hat
meine Damen und Herren andere schaffen
darüber Fakten und wir schauen zu und
als wenn es bestellt gewesen wäre aber
es war natürlich nicht bestellt lassen
sie mich aus dem heutigen Handelsblatt
zitieren
der Kontinent macht sich zum Mars aller
Dinge und verärgert so wichtige
Handelspartner Selbstbezogenheit der EU
und manche ihrer Mitgliedstaaten im
Artikel kommt insbesondere Deutschland
zum Ausdruck wirkt irritierend diesen
Artikel diesen Namensartikel von heute
stammt von den früheren
Parteivorsitzenden sharping und Gabriel
ich kann Ihnen nur zustimmen ja man muss
die großen Ziele verfolgen aber auch man
muss mit den kleinen Schritten beginnen
und darum für fordere ich die jetzige
Regierung auf und die Koalition
ratifizieren sie die Handel kommen als
Schritte der Machbarkeit die jetzt auf
dem Tisch liegen ich wünsche ihnen sehr
viel Erfolg bei G7 der Gemeinsamkeit der
Geschlossenheit in dieser
internationalen Runde aber dazu bedarf
es natürlich auch erst einmal der
Geschlossenheit in der Bundesregierung
und in der Koalition und daran hapert es
leider Gottes scharfan sie erst mal da
entsprechend an besten Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
war das Mitglied im Auswärtigen
Ausschuss wie auch der nächste Redner
Andreas lahrem für die SPD-Fraktion
steht hier schon bereit die Frage lautet
nächster Redner ist der Kollege Andreas
lagem SPD-Fraktion zu seiner ersten
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren
seit dem 1 Januar 2022 hat Deutschland
den Vorsitz der G7 die Bundesregierung
hat hierzu in der letzten Woche ein
ausführliches Programm vorgestellt die
Schwerpunkte sind Klima Gesundheit und
die Stärkung der Demokratie
die Komik 19 Pandemie ist allgegenwärtig
70 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung soll nach
dem Willen der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation bis 2022
geimpft sein die Bundesregierung
unterstützt die WHO bei der Erreichung
dieses Ziels
dafür soll die globale Impfkampagne
beschleunigt werden und die lokale
impfproduktion in den
Entwicklungsländern weiter unterstützt
werden die Bundesregierung will
weiterhin die Präsidentschaft nutzen um
die leidende und koordinierende Rolle
der WHO auszubauen
insgesamt nimmt die Bundesregierung die
Agenda 2030 mit ihren
Nachhaltigkeitszielen zum zentralen
Referenzrahmen für die
g7-präsidentschaft
die Pandemie hat zu schweren
Rückschlägen bei der Erreichung der
Nachhaltigkeitsziele geführt die G7
sehen wir in besonderer Verantwortung
die Nachhaltigkeitsziele ambitioniert
umzusetzen lokal national und global
hier sei insbesondere das Ziel der
Gleichstellung der Geschlechter genannt
im Rahmen der g7-präsidentschaft wollen
wir die Gleichstellung auch global
voranbringen besonders wichtig ist uns
in diesen unruhigen Zeiten dass die
Bundesregierung die Rolle der G7 als
Brückenbauer und Vermittler für Frieden
und Sicherheit stärken will
fest eingebettet in die multilaterale
regelbasierte Ordnung insbesondere die
Vereinten Nationen will sie mit den G7
Lösungswege für Krisenlagen entwickeln
und an deren Umsetzung arbeiten dabei
sollen Krisenprävention und Abrüstung im
Mittelpunkt stehen
wir wollen demokratische Institutionen
und Menschenrechte schützen und stärken
auch die Wahrnehmung des internationalen
Rechts werden wir mit Nachdruck
verteidigen
zur besseren Prävention wollen wir die
vorausschauende humanitäre Hilfe stärken
um drohende und Klima induzierte
humanitäre Krisen bereits im Vorfeld zu
verhindern und dabei ist es besonders
wichtig die Freiheit und Integrität von
Informationen sicherzustellen freie und
unabhängige Medien und gesicherte und
verlässliche Informationen spielen für
starke Demokratien eine zentrale Rolle
die demokratische
Meinungsbildungsprozesse müssen
Verfälschungen und Verzerrungen
vorverfälschung und vor Verzerrungen
geschützt werden Hassreden bekämpft
Meinungsfreiheit sichergestellt und die
Sicherheit von Journalistinnen und
Journalisten gewährleistet werden
anknüpfend an bestehende Prozesse wollen
wir in der G7 geeignete präventive
Ansätze zur Verbesserung der
informationsintegrität entwickeln und
unsere Bürgerinnen und Bürger noch
besser dabei unterstützen
Desinformationen und
Verschwörungsideologien zu erkennen und
aktiv entgegenzutreten können
zusätzlich wollen wir die
Wissenschaftskommunikation Stärken meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren die